Und damit zum letzten Mal. Herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Ich spreche in Mikrofon und werde versuchen, in den nächsten zwei Stunden Netzsachen zu besprechen, und zwar sowohl mit euch als auch mit den Leuten, die dieser Sendung ihren Namen geben, nämlich Vertreter des Chaos Computer Clubs. Und ich begrüße recht herzlich Mutag, Sanimo und Fraps Tach. Und wir machen heute, also weil der Chaos Computer Club ist ja immer sehr weit vorn. Das merkt man ja auch, wenn wir die Themen sozusagen in der Sendung besprechen. Und deswegen sind wir auch eine der ersten, die heute Jahresrückblick machen. Ist ja noch November, aber trotzdem, weil es schon die letzte Sendung im Jahr ist. Und wollen also den nächsten zwei Stunden sozusagen darüber sprechen, was sind denn so die netzpolitischen digitalen, warte, Cyber Highlights 2017 oder? Okay, das wird, das wird eine interessante zwei Stunden. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Und ihr dürft auch mitmachen, wenn ihr wollt. Und zwar entweder könnt ihr gerne hier vorbeikommen. Wir sind im Fräulein Fritz. Wir machen zum Ende des Jahres noch eine Premiere Chaosradio zum ersten Mal live aus Berlin. Und ihr könnt ihr also live in der Mikrofon sprechen, wenn ihr von eurem Cyber Moment 2017 erzählen wollt. Oder ihr könnt tatsächlich auch das tun, was man im Blumen so im Allgemeinen tut.
Jetzt anrufen 0331 70 97 110.
Und um das Ganze persönlich zu machen, möchte ich sozusagen von den hier Anwesenden in jeder halben Stunde, in die sich die Sendung immer gut unterteilen lässt, einen What the fuck Moment 2017 abfragen und werde selber mit gutem Beispiel vorangehen. Und dann gehen wir so ein bisschen das Jahr durch, was so passiert ist und orientieren uns da vor allen Dingen auch an Dingen, die im Chaosradio so passiert sind. Mein What the fuck Moment ist einer, dem ich leider dann nicht mehr hinterher gegoogelt habe, weil ja mit den Snowden liegs weiter so, dass man also wirklich alles, was mit Überwachungstechnik geht, wird auch gemacht. Und dann war ich dann so, okay, also irgendwie Geheimdienste packen deine Rechner, die du bestellt hast, ausbauen, überwachungstechnik rein und dann schicken sie das weiter und so, okay, alles klar, jetzt hab ich wirklich alles gesehen. Und ich habe jetzt tatsächlich kürzlich erst auf Twitter ein Bild gesehen von einem Netzwerkkabel, wo ein Mikrofon drin war. Da hieß es okay, also ich hätte gedacht, wenigstens sowas wie ein Netzwerkkabel, was ja im Prinzip für unsere allgemeine Technik ein sowas ähnliches ist, wie eine Wäscheleine, ist sicher. Aber selbst da kann man dann noch Dinge einbauen, die uns belauschen oder beschnüffeln. Was ich jetzt von euch gerne wissen würde, hat das einer von euch gesehen und ist das wahr? Oder hat sich denn jemand nur entüblen, was wäre wenn Scherz erlaubt?
Also ich habe es auf jeden Fall auch gesehen und ich habe es nicht physikalisch in der Hand gehabt, aber ich kann mir echt gut vorstellen, dass das schon möglich ist. Also halt ein Mikrofon ist jetzt nicht so riesig und das Netzwerkkabel, was ja doch sehr groß ist und vor allem, wo Strom drüber transportiert wird, kann man ja eigentlich super so ein Mikrofon mit drin verstecken. Also das ist bestimmt möglich, also halte ich für sehr wahrscheinlich.
Also das ist nicht nur technisch möglich, es ist auch technisch plausibel sogar.
Ich würde sagen, es ist auch plausibel und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass wenn man irgendwo in den richtigen Shops sucht, man das auch als Autonormalverbraucher bestellen kann.
Was? Okay, also falls euch irgendjemand dubioses fragt, ich habe diese schönen neuen bunten Netzwerkkabel. Möchtest du nicht die anstelle dieser hässlichen alten, die du in der Wohnung hast, nehmen?
Ich fand eigentlich viel erschreckender das kleine USB-Kabel, was ein GSM Modem drin hatte und ein Handy und dann wie ein USB-Stromkabel fürs Handy aussieht, aber in Wirklichkeit ein Funkmodem mit Handy-Netzanbindung hat.
Und damit dann was macht?
Mikrofon und Daten und alles. Die Technik ist wirklich klein geworden mittlerweile. Die passt in so einen kleinen USB-Stecker.
Was mich tatsächlich verwundert ist, es gibt ja mittlerweile überall auch USB-Dosen. Also in der Wand, im Hotel. Im Bus, genau, in öffentlichen Nahverkehrsmitteln. Und überhaupt fragt man ja ab und zu, kann mir jemand Strom geben? Und da sag ich mir, ja klar, hier schließt doch irgendwie an mein völlig harmlos aussehendes Netzgerät ein, das händieren. Und es gibt ja das sogenannte USB-Kondom, also USB-Kabel, die tatsächlich sozusagen so gebaut sind, dass sie nur, da sind dann irgendwie nur zwei Leitungen belegt, glaube ich.
Ja, das hilft dir aber auch nicht mehr.
Stopp, halt. Ich möchte das erst mal, möchte ich das erklären. Also USB-Kondom ist ja so nur zwei Stromkabel.
Fast.
Okay, nehme ich.
Also das fiese ist, das ging früher.
Nein, jetzt sag doch erst mal, wie es funktioniert, bevor wir es kaputt machen.
Du weißt halt schon, dass nur Strom ins Gerät reinkommt.
Genau, und wie macht man das?
Und dass aus dem Rechner nur Strom kommt. Das heißt im Prinzip verbindest du mit dem Handy oder mit dem Stromabnehmer, die du aufladen möchtest, wirklich nur die beiden Stromleitungen. Du musst aber mit ein bisschen Elektronik dem Gerät, was den Strom gibt, auch sagen, wie viel Strom da rauskommen soll. Das heißt, wir reden jetzt mittlerweile miteinander, leider.
Aber was mich gewundert ist, dass das nicht zur Produktkategorie wird. Also das nicht den Leuten, das klar geworden ist, okay, mit USB kann man wirklich viel, viel Ärger machen, aber das ist schon auch praktisch, überall USB zu haben. Wieso ist das nicht das meistverkaufte Technologieprodukt des Jahres? Jetzt beginne ich eine Idee davon zu kommen, weil auch das kaputt ist. Warum ist das kaputt?
Na ja, letztendlich, was Mutags schon angesprochen hat, du kannst ja nicht einfach, es gibt ja 3000 USB-Standards und Reflexion-Devices mit mehr oder weniger Stromhunger und du kannst jetzt nicht einfach hingehen und volle Möhre da Strom drauf brettern, so was das rechts unten Device gerne an Strom hätte, sondern du musst erst mal so vorsichtig anfangen, sag mal, du Gerät, ich gebe jetzt mal genug Spannung drauf, um mit dir zu reden und sag mal, mit wieviel kämpfst du eigentlich klar oder wieviel hättest du gerne? Und dann sag deine Powerbank, yeah, gib alles. Und dann kriegst du auch alles, wenn du Glück hast und am richtigen Port steckst, wie die meisten sicherlich wissen.
Es fing eigentlich damit an, dass der USB-Standard nicht mehr so standardisiert ist, wie er mal war. Also der Standard gibt ja relativ wenig.
Doch, es gibt da jetzt ganz viele von.
Genau, und dann hat man halt 20.000 Dinge draufgepackt, die dann mehr machen, aber dann muss man von diesen üblichen, wir haben zwei Leitungen für Strom und zwei für Daten, kamen dann plötzlich, wir haben vier für Strom und vier für Daten und man kann alles über alles sprechen und darüber kommunizieren und dann kann man auch noch sagen, dass man viel mehr macht, als was das USB eigentlich kann und dann muss man schon, dass die richtigen Kabel mit den richtigen Ports und den Powerbanks. Fernsehgucken sind aber auch. Genau, es ist viel zu verwirrend gewesen und ja, es gibt halt jetzt verschiedene USB-Kabel und Stecker und weil du willst ja das Notbrauch den USB-Anschluss aufladen.
Theoretische Frage ist sozusagen, was ist, wenn ich den jetzt zu einem Kabel anschließe, wo wirklich nur der Strom verbunden ist? Was schießt denn das Gerät raus? Einfach den Maximalstrom?
Es werden wahrscheinlich 5 Volt und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, maximal 500 mAh kommen, das Handy wird drei Wochen brauchen, bis es aufgeladen ist.
Genau, also für ein aktuelles Handy wird das wahrscheinlich lange.
Der Akku wird dann leerer.
Also das Problem, dass da drin jetzt Elektronik ist, die mit dem Computer redet oder der USB-Box redet und sagt, gib mir mal so und so viel Strom, ist, dass man dann über dieses Kabel auch wieder hacken kann oder?
Na, das heißt halt, dass nicht nur diese beiden Leitungen verbunden werden können. Gerade bei den neuen USB-Standards, also jetzt nicht nur USB 3 oder so, wird es halt deutlich komplizierter, weil auch irgendwie glaube ich 48 Volt dann irgendwann drüber gehen sollen, mehrere Ampere, weil du jetzt auch das komplette Notebook dann damit bedienen können oder aufladen können. Für so ein Handy wird das noch einfach gehen, aber das wird auch nicht mehr lange so gehen. Also Beispiel, wenn ich in einem alten Auto...
Warte, lass mich die Frage einfach stellen. Wenn ich mir jetzt ein USB-Kondom kaufe, bin ich dann momentan sicher oder nicht?
Na du bist sicher, aber wahrscheinlich kommt nur ganz wenig... also du wirst wenig Spaß mit diesem USB-Kondom haben, weil du wahrscheinlich nie dein Telefon mal eben schnell laden kannst.
Aber ich kann es weiter betreiben.
Ein Handy, das gerade Navigation macht mit Google Maps unterwegs im Auto zum Beispiel, braucht deutlich mehr Strom, als ich darüber reinbringen kann. Also wenn ich ein Handy an den USB-Anschluss vom Autoradio anschließe, der nur 500 mAh macht, wird der Akku leerer, während es da angeschlossen ist, weil es mehr verbraucht, als ich nachladen kann.
Ja, aber das ist ja dann so. Da kann ja der Buchstab trotzdem nicht sagen, gibt mir mehr Strom, wenn sie den nicht hat.
Genau. Aber das wird halt dann auch passieren.
Es gibt... Ja, ja.
Du kennst das mit diesen sicheren Passwort-Regeln, die eigentlich alles besser machen sollen, aber was im Endeffekt doch nicht tun, weil sich niemand da hält.
Ne, ne, ne, Moment mal, also sozusagen, also das Handy wird nicht so schnell voll, ist eine andere Kategorie als das kann darüber gehackt werden. Also das Handy wird nicht so schnell voll, kann ich mit leben?
Ja, aber deswegen benutzt es niemand, weil das lädt dann nicht auf und dann lässt du es weg und dann lädt es schneller und dann funktioniert es.
Hä, aber wieso lädt es dann schneller, das verstehe ich nicht.
Wenn du das USB-Kondom weglässt, dann kann das Handy direkt der Powerbank sagen, ich hätte jetzt gerne zwei Ampere oder vier Ampere und lädt dann schnell. Deswegen ist es viel bequemer, das wegzulassen und nicht zu benutzen.
Das heißt, ich bräuchte sagen ein USB-Kondom, was auf mein Handy eingestellt ist. Dann würde es funktionieren.
Ja, das muss man mit dem Handy reden, fragen, wie viel hättest du denn gerne und muss dann mit der Powerbank reden und sagen, so hätte ich gerne.
Das kann ja auch theoretisch auch sagen, ich habe einen sozusagen Blafone 10 und dann kann ich dafür das extra, das USB-Kondom. Ich meine, das wäre doch auch eine Markluke, da könntest du auch wieder 100.000 verschiedene Produkte erstellen. Für jedes Handy das eigene USB-Kondom.
Also wenn es das noch nicht gibt, solltest du das unbedingt tun und deine Firma dafür aufmachen.
Mal Kriegstarter.
Ich bin raus hier.
Tschüss, wer macht die Sendung weiter?
Ich weiß auch nicht so genau, aber vielleicht können wir dann erst mal drüber sprechen, was sonst auch so im Jahr passiert ist. Ich finde es aber schön, dass man von jedem Ding, wo man kommt, das ist doch wenigstens eine kleine gute Nachricht, dass ihr dann wieder Dinge sagt, die mich die Hände über den Kopf zusammenschlagen lassen.
Nur dafür bist du hier.
Nur dafür bin ich hier. Genau. So, dann lass uns doch mal durchgehen, was sonst so passiert ist. Jetzt ist es ja so, wir haben in der Sendung auch Nerd News, werden wir auch hier wieder heute einen Start bringen und da haben wir Anfang des Jahres vermeldet, dass die Führung der FCC sich verändert hat. Erklärt mal bitte für alle, die es nicht wissen, wer ist der FCC und wer ist da neu eingeführt worden?
Das ist ein Fußballverein, oder?
Komm, für die dummen Anfängerwitze bin ich zuständig und du musst es erklären.
Ich weiß gerade wirklich nicht, was die Abkürzung heißt.
So, das ist die...
Das Netzagentur der USA kann man eigentlich grob übersetzen. Die kümmert sich halt darum, wer wie mit wem redet und die standardisieren das bzw. die spielen halt in Amerika den Regulierer für diesen Markt, also für Telefon und Internet.
Also jetzt halt nicht mehr.
Nein, du darfst nicht erst um eine Scherze machen und dann Insider. Das geht nicht. Jetzt musst du mal schön erklären, wer ist da neu dazugekommen und warum ist das wichtig?
Also der Chef wurde zumindest ausgetauscht von dieser Organisation.
Adetai ist der neue Mensch.
Genau und statt zu sagen, wie so ein Regulierer das hat, der soll ja eigentlich gucken, dass der Markt fair ist und dass jeder die gleichen Chancen hat, egal wie groß, wie klein, wie viel Geld oder wie wenig Geld, oder ob der ganz Amerika oder nur eine kleine Stadt auf dem Land bedient, dass alle die gleichen Möglichkeiten haben. So dazu ist eigentlich so ein Regulierer da. Nur der neue Chef sagt eigentlich mehr oder weniger so, naja das regelt der Markt ja eigentlich schon, das ist ja Marktwirtschaft. Da muss man ja nichts regulieren, macht das doch mal unter euch aus.
Und das ist viel zu viel Bürokratie und alles viel zu unfair. Und überhaupt, wenn der Markt das nicht selber regeln kann, dann wird das nichts mehr mit dem Internet in den USA.
Jetzt ist es ja so, dass wenn man in die USA guckt und sagt, da läuft es gerade schlimm, dann ist ja eigentlich immer Trump daran schuld. Ist der jetzt auch daran schuld?
Ja, er hat den berufen.
Aha, ja, also er hat den Chef dahingeschätzt.
Okay, und das ist ja lustigerweise sozusagen, schließt es ja fast wie den Bogen jetzt zum Ende des Jahres, weil in zwei Wochen, am 14. Dezember, entscheidet die FCC, wo das jetzt gerade der neue Chef ist, der von Trump eingesetzt wurde, über die Netzneutralität.
Da wäre jetzt eigentlich nur die Frage, hat Trump auch einen Internetprovider oder ist er an irgendjemand beteiligt? Weil das weiß ich jetzt tatsächlich nicht.
Naja, ich würde von...
Er müsste ja bestimmt einen Nutzen davon haben.
Also ich würde jetzt sagen, also erkennt Trump Leute, die ihm Geld geben, die ja einen Internetprovider haben? Bestimmt, ja. Möglicherweise. Aber was ist genau passiert bei der Netzneutralität? Was ist da der Plan der aktuelle, der FCC?
Ja, dass man halt eigentlich da nichts mehr reguliert, sondern es ist halt einfach.
Also es ist ganz interessant, so die großen Internetprovider, so Comcast beispielsweise, Verizon, die sind halt hergegangen und haben gesagt, das ist hier alles ganz furchtbar, wir würden hier so gerne irgendwie verschiedene Güteklassen an Internet anbieten. Und überhaupt, dieses ganze Netflix macht hier unser Netz kaputt und der Netflix soll auch bitte auch mal was zahlen dafür, dass er hier durch unsere Netze darf. Und das ist ja alles ganz, ganz furchtbar. Und dem wird halt weitestgehend, zumindest auf einer regulatorischen Ebene, war das bisher so nicht möglich, dass man jetzt, oder war explizit verboten, dass man diese Bevorzugung einzelner Anbieter machen konnte als Internetanbieter, sondern es war erst mal nur ein Internetprovider soll dir Daten liefern, er soll dir IP-Pakete liefern. Es soll ihm völlig egal sein, was in diesen Paketen drin ist, ob da jetzt ein Video vom Netflix drin ist oder irgendwie der Brief von deiner Liebsten oder deinen Liebsten und völlig egal. Da soll einfach IP rüberkommen. Und die sagen jetzt halt, ja, Momentchen mal, Momentchen mal, die machen uns doch viel mehr Arbeit und überhaupt und das geht nicht. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt eine Ungleichbehandlung einführen. Das entspricht zu einer gewissen liberalen Marktwirtschaftslogik, ist natürlich für das, was das Internet bisher immer ausgemacht hat, der absolute Tod. Also kann man so sehen, dann braucht man aber kein Internet mehr.
Also vor allem kann man das halt schon in anderen Ländern sehen, wo es schon einen Schritten weiter ist. Da kannst du dann zum Beispiel auf deinem Handy, statt dass du ein Internetpaket kaufst wie hier, wo dann halt irgendwie fünf Gigabyte im Monat hast, kaufst du dir ein sogenanntes zum Beispiel WTF-Paket. Da kannst du dann WhatsApp, Twitter und Facebook benutzen. Und der Rest ist halt teuer oder nicht möglich oder gar nicht so viel möglich.
Du wolltest ein WTF-Moment.
Es ging nämlich um dieses Künstler drum aus Portugal, glaube ich.
Ja, Portugal zum Beispiel hat das ein Freund, der gerade in Afrika unterwegs hatte, das auch gesehen. Also es ist immer gang G bei den Mobile-Providern, dass die es schon anbieten und halt sagen, du kannst dir halt Pakete kaufen. Und wenn du jetzt irgendwie arbeiten willst, dann kannst du dir ja dein Office-Paket kaufen, lass dann auch VPN in die Firma, so eine Fernverbindung in die Firma erlaubt. Wenn du aber nicht arbeiten willst auf deinem Telefon, dann reicht dir wahrscheinlich auch Facebook und Twitter. Dann musst du ja auch fürs andere nicht zahlen. Willst du aber Musik hören, musst du vielleicht wieder ein bisschen mehr für Musik bezahlen.
Und wird das dann auch so, ist es dann auch so, dass quasi die, wenn man die Einzelpreise der Pakete zusammenrechnet, dass das viel, viel teurer ist als bei uns einmal ganz Internet?
Ist wahrscheinlich am Ende sogar viel teurer, wenn man dort das einmal alles kauft, sozusagen. Das ist so ein bisschen wie, ja, plus was halt daraus rauskommt, weil der Provider muss ja auch wissen, ob du jetzt Facebook oder Twitter benutzt oder ob das dein Spotify ist oder wie auch immer alle heißen. Und das heißt halt auch wiederum, dass er deine Daten irgendwie in einem gewissen Maße mitlesen muss, um das auszuwerten, wo dein Internet Provider eigentlich sagen sollte, ich geb dir Pakete und du schaust, dass die ans andere Ende kommen. Aber du schaust nur, wo die hin sollen und nicht was da drin ist. Aber wenn man dann zum Beispiel auf so einer Service Ebene sagt, so der eine Dienst ja, der andere Dienst nein, dann muss man ja wirklich genau reinschauen in die Pakete, was da drin steht.
Aber ich würde jetzt mal was Positives sehen, wenn das passiert, dann würde ich in Zukunft einfach nur das Verschlüsselungs-VPN-Paket kaufen und nur noch verschlüsselte Services benutzen, weil dann kann der ISP nicht mehr reingucken, also der Internet Provider und dann ist ja das eine gute Sache, weil dann auf einmal alle im Netz verschlüsseln oder?
Das wird ja auch keiner zahlen am Ende. Wieso braucht man es denn? Das kostet ja dann alles Geld und nicht jeder weiß.
Man müsste nur ein Paket bezahlen.
Ja, ja, aber das setzt voraus, dass alle deine Endgeräte problemlos mit diesem VPN klarkommen, dass alle Apps auf deinem Telefon problemlos mit über dieses VPN auch laufen.
Meint ihr nicht, dass das sozusagen der Markt, der Antrieb für den Markt ist, Verschlüsselung zu schaffen für alle?
Nein.
Schade, war nur so eine Idee. Jetzt ist bei diesem FCC-Ding ja auch so, dass es immer wieder Meldungen gibt, dass die so eine Online-Petition, also irgendwie Userinnen und User, beteiligen sich und sagen, ja geil, wir wollen genau das, was ihr wollt, nämlich keine Netzneutralität mehr und dann immer wieder rauskommen, okay, das ist alles gefaked. Habt ihr das irgendwie auch verfolgt?
Das Einzige, was ich verfolgt habe, war ganz lustig. Comcast hatte einen Pledge, ein Versprechen für die Netzneutralität auf ihrer Webseite. Und das ist jetzt, als wo diese Entscheidung ansteht, jetzt in ein paar Wochen mysteriöserweise von dieser Webseite verschwunden. Ganz seltsam.
Wo man könnte glatt meinen, die profitieren unter Umständen davon?
Nee, das halte ich für völlig ausgeschlossen.
Wie ist das denn jetzt eigentlich hier in Deutschland? Also ich habe neulich mit Ulf Bromheier gesprochen von der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und der meint, naja, weiß man nicht so genau, entweder könnte man vielleicht sagen, ey, geil, die machen das so, dann machen wir das auch so. Aber vielleicht ist es auch so, dass das dann für uns eher zum Ansporn wird, zu sagen, ja, wenn die das so falsch machen, dann machen wir das hier richtig, richtig. Und Netzneutralität ist dann das Geilste von der Welt. Und alle Daten sind gleich. Und wie ist denn da die politische Stimmung gerade?
Na, die Richtung geht ja schon so dahin. Also man schaut ja irgendwie die Telekom und dieses Stream-On-Paket gebaut, womit Streaming-Dienstleistungen außerhalb von deinem Vertragsvolumen sozusagen abgerechnet werden. Also zahlst halt ein bisschen was im Monat, damit gewisse Daten, die du über dein Telefon machst, einfach überhaupt nicht so wirklich gezählt werden.
Also das kostet extra.
Du zahlst halt ein bisschen was extra, damit eine gewisse Datenmenge von deinem Telefon einfach rausgenommen wird, in diesen kleinen Extra-Betrag gepackt wird, aber nicht deine restlichen Daten macht. Wenn du jetzt super viele Videos auf deinem Tablet guckst und das über das Mobilfunknetz, dann würden diese Videos nicht auf dein Datenvolumen gebucht werden, sondern nur noch Twitter und Facebook.
Aber halt nur, wenn der Anbieter da auch mitspielt und dafür Geld bezahlt.
Genau. Und da lassen sich von beiden Seiten Geld geben.
Naja, noch nicht. Der Deal ist ja im Moment, oder das Gefährliche an dieser Sache ist, dass wenn man sich diesen Vertrag durchliest, dass eigentlich der größte Gefahr für einen Anbieter ist, wenn er eine gewisse Reaktionszeit von der Telekom nicht einhält, weil dann zahlt er richtig, richtig fies Strafgebühren. Was sich natürlich auch kleinere Buden überhaupt nicht leisten können.
Ich hatte gedacht, dass die Idee hinter der Abschaffung der Rechtsneutralität ist, dass die Internetprovider dann doppelt kassieren. Also einmal sagen sie dem Enduser, hey, kauf uns ein geiles Video Streaming Paket. Und andererseits sagen sie dem Video Streaming Anbieter, hey, wenn du deine Daten schnell zu unseren Kunden und Kundinnen bringen willst, dann musst du noch mal extra bezahlen.
Das wäre die Idee, das ist aber so noch nicht legal.
Na ja, jetzt gibt es ja schon mit, wir bringen die Daten zu deinem Kunden, aber bei manchen Daten, die uns besonders lieb sind, da können wir mal zwei Augen zudrücken und berechnen die nicht so wirklich.
Und das sorgt halt für eine super Marktverzerrung, weil wenn ich auf meinem Handy bin und die Entscheidung habe, nehme ich jetzt die Musik von diesem Anbieter, wo es nicht auf mein Datenvolumen geht, oder bezahle ich dann den anderen Anbieter?
Aber es ist doch diskriminierungsfrei, da kann sich doch jeder melden bei der Telekom und das einfach auch machen.
Genau, deswegen ist ja media.ccc.de auch da drin.
Oh wait, nee, es ist nicht.
Insider Alarm, erklären.
Na ja, es gab mal den...
Also die Telekom hat ursprünglich gesagt, jeder darf sich sozusagen da eintragen, dass er Teil dieses Stream-on-Dingens hat.
Genau, aber dazu muss man erstmal einen dicken Vertrag unterschreiben. Das haben sich die Kollegen von netzpolitik.org mal schicken lassen. Die haben mal so ein Performa-Streaming-Webseite aufgemacht und haben dann bei der Telekom angefragt und gesagt, okay, wenn das hier diskriminierungsfrei ist, dann dürfen wir doch jetzt sicherlich auch mitmachen. Hier ist unsere Webseite. Was müssen wir denn unterschreiben und welche technischen Vorkehrungen müssen wir da treffen? Und die Telekom sagte dann so, ja, hier ist das Vertragswerk und übrigens Vertragsstrafen, wenn ihr euch an gewisse Dinge nicht haltet. Und außerdem gab es dann so ganz komische Klauseln, wie wenn die Dateien frei runterladbar sind und nicht nur streambar sind, dann kann man diesen Vertrag nicht wirklich eingehen, weil die Idee natürlich ist, dass die Telekom diese Daten möglichst reduzieren will. Also dass jetzt nicht in maximal bester Qualität die Dateien darüber gehen, was ja auf deinem Handy möglicherweise völlig okay ist, weil kleines Display und so.
Also die sagen so, natürlich kannst du Netflix streamen, zum Beispiel, oder einen Videoprogramm deiner Wahl, aber du kriegst das nicht in Full HD. Du kriegst es halt nur in weniger, weil Full HD würde ja das Netz ein bisschen belasten.
Also die wollen ja wirklich, also das sind zwei, das sind zwei.
Warte mal, sie verkaufen mir sozusagen gutes Netz und sagen dann aber nicht, dass gute Netz benutzen?
Und das einzige, was ich immer noch scary finde, weil sie müssen ja die Dienste differenzieren. Und während jetzt bei der Telekom mit dem Stream-on-Paket eventuell noch relativ einfach möglich ist, wenn dann aber anfängst irgendwie sozusagen so Twitter und Facebook geht, aber irgendwie mein Outlook-Webclient und meinen Firmen VPR nicht mehr, heißt sie müssen relativ viel reinschauen, die Pakete. Das heißt, die bauen da eine richtig große Infrastruktur auf, um genau zu sehen, was in deinen Paketen vor sich geht. Und da könnte man natürlich jetzt sagen, wenn so eine Infrastruktur die richtig tiefen Pakete reinschauen kann, schon mal da steht, wo alles durchgeht.
Wir brauchen Upload-Filter.
Na, da kann man ja einfach mal irgendwie genauer hinschauen, weil man schaut, ob das Twitter ist, man schaut, ob es Facebook ist, und dann kann man vielleicht auch noch reinschauen, was denn dieser WhatsApp-Nachricht stand von dieser Person.
Man könnte die Vorratsratsprechung ein bisschen ausweiten, meinste?
Na ja, die Mechanismen dazu sind da. Man muss dann wahrscheinlich nur ein paar mehr Buttons klicken und vielleicht noch eine Lizenz kaufen.
Okay, ich möchte kurz, weil die erste halbe Stunde gleich wieder vorbei ist, nochmal die Frage stellen, also die Firmen wollen das gerne und versuchen das mit aller Macht, haben wir gerade so auf verschiedene Art und Weise erklärt. Wie ist denn die politische Stimmung in Deutschland?
Na, die politische Stimmung ist im Moment gar nicht, wie du vielleicht mitbekommen hast.
Wie wäre die politische Stimmung? Also da kann man keine anderen Fragen haben. Haben die Parteien eine Meinung dazu oder lassen die sie einfach von den Lobbyisten in der großen Firmen vor sich her treiben?
Also die großen lassen sich ziemlich von den Lobbyisten der Firmen her treiben, weil natürlich diese Pakete heißen, man kann den Kunden mehr verkaufen, sprich man macht mehr Umsatz und Gewinn und das tut ja auch der Aktie gut und den ganzen Shareholner das ist ja schon wichtig.
Aber die Politiker auch?
Und selbstfahrende Autos.
Ja, die selbstfahrenden Autos und Telemedizin ist ja auch wichtig.
Leute, ihr könnt nicht kurz bevor die Nachrichten kommen irgendwie noch ein neues Thema anschneiden.
Aber, ähm...
Politiker.
Denke ich mal, einige Politiker kriegen dann natürlich von Lobbyisten entsprechend das schmackhaft gemacht, dass sie gegen die Netzneutralität sein sollten, weil dadurch kann man mehr Geld verdienen. Während andere Politiker halt dann doch eher so sagen, nee, das Netz muss neutral bleiben und wir sind ziemlich sehr für die Netzneutralität.
Ist das letztlich dann an Parteifarben festmachen?
Ich glaube so 100% nicht, aber ich kann mal bestimmt sagen, glaube ich, dass die Linken relativ für die Netzneutralität sind. Und für die Grünen auch. Und glaube, schwarz-rot ist natürlich gegen die Netzneutralität, weil das mögen die Konzerne ja nicht.
Okay, gut. Letzte Frage. Das heißt also für den Notiz-Zettel 2018, Themen, die wir beobachten und möglicherweise aktiv werden müssen, Netzneutralität.
Und ganz wichtig, sich nicht von...
Sagst du erstmal ja oder nein?
Ja.
Gut.
Und? Aber? Wenn ihr irgendwie Stream-On-Kunde seid, lasst euch nicht fürführend von YouHoo, Spotify, ist kostenlos. Das ist nur der erste Schuss, der es angenehm macht. Und dann wird es hässlich.
Alles klar. So, wir haben jetzt ein kleines bisschen Musik. Dann gibt es nachher den Wetter und den Verkehr. Dann machen wir weiter. Und die Musik kommt in dieser Sendung von Ketzer. Die hat Netzmusik rausgebracht. Das Album heißt Firmament. Und der erste Track, den wir jetzt davon hören, der heißt Arch. Danach Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr. Und danach geht es weiter hier im Chaos Radio in Blumen im Fräulein Fritz.
So liebe Fritz-Hörer, in diesem feierlichen Moment wollen wir euch vor allen anwesenden Fritzen fragen. Wollt ihr wieder singen, tanzen, schwitzen und die T-Shirts fliegen lassen? Dann antwortet jetzt mit Martheri.
Fritz präsentiert.
Montag, 18. Dezember. Martheria, live in der Mark Schwedinghalle.
Hey, das muss irre werden. Ich will das Berlin-Ding muss jetzt richtig weggerockt werden.
Nachrichten.
Mit Linus Busch. Zum ersten Mal seit der Bundestagswahl haben Union und SPD miteinander über eine mögliche neue Regierung gesprochen. Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat die Parteichefs am Abend im Schloss Bellevue empfangen. Führende SPD-Politiker sind aber weiter skeptisch. So hat SPD-Vizepräsident Stegner erneut eine Minderheitsregierung ins Spiel gebracht. Innenminister de Maizière von der CDU will darüber aber noch nicht nachdenken. Der Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung sagte er, die Union versuche ernsthaft, mit den Sozialdemokraten eine stabile Regierung zu bilden. Deutschland zieht einen Diplomaten aus Nordkorea ab. Das hat Außenminister Gabriel in Washington mitgeteilt. Damit reagiert die Bundesregierung auf den letzten Raketentest Nordkoreas. Die Botschaft in der nordkoreanischen Hauptstadt Pyongyang soll aber nicht komplett geschlossen werden. Das hatten die USA eigentlich gefordert. Nordkorea hatte gestern erneut eine Langstreckenrakete getestet. In der AfD bahnt sich möglicherweise ein neuer Machtkampf an. Nach ARD-Informationen denkt der AfD-Fraktionschef im Bundestag Gauland darüber nach, für den Parteivorsitz zu kandidieren. Damit könnte es auf dem Bundesparteitag an diesem Wochenende zu einer Kampfabstimmung kommen. Der Berliner Landesef Pasterzki hat nämlich schon Anfang der Woche erklärt, dass er AfD-Chef werden will. Er geht als Vertreter des gemäßigteren Flügels in der AfD. Der amtierende Parteichef Meuthen will ebenfalls wieder antreten. Die Berliner CDU wirft dem rot-rot-grünen Senat Versagen beim neuen Flughafen BER vor. Die letzten Berichte über Mängel und Risiken zeigten, dass der Senat seiner Verantwortung nicht gerecht werde, sagte CDU-Generalsekretär Ewas im Abgeordnetenhaus. Auch Vertreter der Koalition äußerten sich in der Debatte besorgt. Kürzlich ist ein TÜV-Bericht bekannt geworden, wonach es immer noch Probleme beim Brandschutz am BER gibt. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Tempelhof und in Pankow sind es 0 Grad, auch in Prenzla und Kallau haben wir 0 in Potsdam und Neuropin 1 Grad. Es ist noch meistens trocken und nur wenig bewölkt. Nach und nach kann es dann aber von Nordosten erste Schneeregen oder auch Schneeschauer geben. Passt dann bitte auf, da kann es dann nämlich glatt werden. Auf 0 bis minus 3 Grad gehen die Temperaturen im Laufe der Nacht runter. Morgen ist es meistens dicht bewölkt und von Nordosten ziehen immer wieder Schnee und Schneeregen durch. Auch am Nachmittag erreichen die Schauer dann den Flaming und die Niederlausitz. 1 bis 4 Grad sind dann Höchsttemperaturen drin. Charlottenburg, die Ulanstraße, ist zwischen Kahnstraße und Steinplatz wegen eines Feuerwehreinsatzes in beiden Richtungen voll gesperrt. In Weißensee ist die Buschallee zwischen Hansastraße und Surmornstraße in Richtung Althohen Schönhausen gesperrt. Grund ist ein Wasserrohrbruch und noch zur S-Bahn-Linie S75. Wegen einer Weichenstörung im Ostbahnhof fahren die Züge weiterhin nur zwischen Wartenberg und Ostkreuz. Davo es geht euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr die laufende Sendung nochmal hören wollt, dann macht das doch. Zusammen mit vielen weiteren öffentlich-rechtlichen Angeboten kostenlos und werbefrei in der App zur ARD-Audiothek.
Heute Chaosradio im Blue Moon, live aus dem Fräulein Fritz. Das heißt unter anderem auch, dass ihr noch live vorbeikommen könnt, wenn ihr wollt. In der Falkensteinstraße am schlesischen Tor hängt ein großes Fritz-Eft in der Luft. Und wenn er da geht, in die Baumhausbahn hinein, könnt ihr hier reinkommen und live der Radiosendung beiwohnen. Wir sprechen heute hier mit den Leuten vom Chaos Computer Club, nämlich Montags, Danimo und Fraps. Hallo. Hallo. Über das Jahr 2017, immer weit vorn, immer der erste Jahresrückblick des Jahres. Und haben gerade schon über Netzneutralität und USB-Kondome gesprochen. Und da fällt mir ein, dass ich sagen wollte, falls ihr nicht kommen könnt, ihr könnt es auch sehen, was wir heute hier machen. Und zwar auf media.ccc.de. Da ist ein Kamerabild, da kann man jetzt mal sehen. Wir haben hier so ein kleines USB-Kondom extra für euch mal in die Kamera gehalten. So sieht sowas aus, falls ihr euch gerade gefragt habt, was ist das eigentlich? Es ist eher kaputt, haben wir gerade geklärt, aber jetzt habt ihr es wenigstens mal gesehen. So, ich wollte ja am Anfang, ach nee, von wegen vorbeikommen. Liebes Pubtrim, das schon da ist, macht mal lautes Geräusch. Ihr hört, die Begeisterung ist groß, aber es ist auch noch Platz. Also kommt her, wenn ihr wollt. Oder ruft an unter 0331 70 97 110, wenn ihr mitmachen wollt beim Jahresrückblick des Chaos Computer Club. So, jetzt wollte ich von jedem immer den What the fuck Moment des Jahres wissen, wer macht's, wer hat, wer hat einen What the fuck Moment für mich?
Ich hätte einen.
Bundestags, bitteschön.
Der ist so ein bisschen globaler. Dass wir letztes Jahr sehr schön beobachten konnten, oder leider nicht sehr schön beobachten konnten, dass Überwachung vollkommen normal wird.
Okay, also das ist jetzt wirklich, das ist schon sehr abstrakt. Ich hätte jetzt gerne sagen, diesen einen Moment wurde 2017 quasi so dieses innerlich aufgehauen, also was?
Es kam so ein bisschen mit dieser Puppe, die im Kinderzimmer war und alles gesprochen in die Cloud geschickt hat, dass die Eltern sich das anhören konnten, was denn das Kind so mit der Puppe spricht.
Naja, aber das ist ja eigentlich kein gutes Beispiel, weil da gab es ja sofort, dass die Gerichtliche sagten, nee Leute, das geht nicht, das ist verdeckte Überwachung. Ihr müsst das, selbst wenn ihr das besitzt, müsst ihr das kaputt machen.
Und das nächste war jetzt die Naughty Cam.
Die was?
Die Naughty Cam, die du im Kinderzimmer hängst. Es ist eine Kameraattrappe, immerhin eine Attrappe, die du an die Decke schraubst oder klebst, die dann rot blinkt mit einer LED. Batteries included, damit die Kinder immer schön überwacht sind und sich brav verhalten vor Weihnachten, weil der Weihnachtsmann guckt da jetzt zu, wenn sie böse sind. Die Elfen? Die Elfen gucken zu, wenn die Kinder sich nicht...
Es ist etwas ein Ding, dass man glaubt, es ist eine gute Idee, Kindern zu sagen, guck mal, da guckt jemand ständig zu.
Ja, genau. Hängt diese Attrappe an die Kinderzimmerdecke, damit die Kinder gleich fühlen, du wirst überwacht und verhalte dich bitte anders.
Das stärkt voll das Vertrauen in die Eltern und erzieht selbstständige denkende Menschen.
Was ich voll und unfassbar ätzend an der Sache ist, dieses Weihnachtsmann-Ding, das ist ja was Magisches, was Mystisches. Der hat so eine Liste, da steht was drauf, aber niemand weiß so genau, wo der da hinkommt. Das hat ja auch eine Geschichte. Und das einfach kaputt zu machen, indem man so ein Ding dahin nennt und damit gleichzeitig noch Überwachung zu normalisieren.
Ist halt ein bisschen greifbarer zu sagen, na der weiß das, weil er eine Kamera in deinem Kinderzimmer installiert hat und nicht weil.
Da braucht man diese ganzen Mystik-Überbau halt nicht mehr.
Ich hasse die Menschheit jetzt gerade ein bisschen. Aber trotzdem, das ist ja nur eine Attrappe.
Ja, weil es erzieht Leute von einem ganz, ganz, ganz frühen Zeitpunkt an zu konformistischem Verhalten.
Ja, zugegeben, aber es ist trotzdem nur eine Attrappe. Also mit der, also richtig klima...
Ich meine, was du da siehst, du siehst halt, wo es in China hingeht. In China musst du jetzt in bestimmten Provinzen halt deine Überwachungs-App auf deinem Handy installieren und wenn du dich nicht konform verhältst, kriegst du entsprechende Strafen.
Es gibt da wirklich Sozial-Conten. Sozial-Conten.
Was heißt das?
Das bedeutet, also das war bisher so ein Ding, dass es in verschiedenen Provinzen gab. Also so ein bisschen wie, als ob hier jedes Bundesland das hätte, nur ein bisschen hoch skaliert. Und das wird jetzt zusammengeführt. Was die Idee dahinter ist, du hast ein Konto und alles, was du tust, Straße fegen, ist was Gutes, kriegst du Punkte gut geschrieben, wenn du die Straße fegst oder regelmäßig fegst. Wenn du eine Zigarettenstummel auf die Straße schmeißt und jemand sieht das, dann gibt das Minuspunkte. Und das hat ganz, ganz reale Auswirkungen auf dein Leben, nämlich ab einem gewissen Punktestand hast du Nachteile im Job, kannst nicht mehr aufsteigen. Dein Arbeitgeber und der Staat, die dir sowieso in anderen Ländern dann da stärker verzahnt sind in diesem speziellen Fall, machen da gemeinsame Sachen. Das heißt, die Dorfgemeinschaft ist das gleiche wie der große Staat, ist das gleiche wie deine Firma und alle haben quasi ein und du hast bei allen ein Sozialkonto und alles hängt mit allem zusammen und du musst dich immer gut verhalten.
Es ist halt die konsequente Weiterentwicklung der Quellen der Telekommunikationsüberwachung, die sie ja hier gegen Straftäter einsetzen wollen. Das heißt, auf deinem Handy ist eine Wand, die auch alle Nachrichten mitliest und dann prüft, ob du zum Beispiel sympathisant von irgendwelchen demokratischen Bewegungen misst.
Das wäre ja auch ein Falschpunkt.
Das ist ja deutlich mehr wie das Quality-Land von Mark-Uwe Kling, wo es auch so darum geht, nur du bist ja eh unter Level 10, damit bist du ja eigentlich nichts wert so als Mensch und man kann halt schnell mal in Level runterfallen oder auch hochkommen.
Ist es nicht in China auch so gedacht, dass dein Score auch davon beeinflusst wird, wen du kennst? Also quasi du kennst jemanden mit einem schlechten Score und dann wird automatisch auch dein Score ein bisschen schlecht?
Ich glaube Sippenhaft gibts da auf jeden Fall auch noch. Weil da bin ich allerdings nicht so wirklich...
Also ich hatte tatsächlich nur zwei Dokumentationen zu gesehen bzw. gehört und da war es vor allen Dingen der individuelle Aspekt und dieser Aspekt, dass diese bisherigen einzelnen Konten so wirklich zentral in ein Register zusammengeführt werden, auf den sie sich da fokussiert haben, inwieweit da Sippenhaft oder Sippenhaftiges verhalten...
Ich meine wirklich zu sagen, dass es ums Social Graph, wie das heißt, also deine Freundin in sozialen Netzwerken, möglicherweise Demokratie-Sympathisanten, aber gut. Falls sich jemand auskennt, 0331-70-97-1-1-0 ist die Telefonnummer und wir haben einen Anrufer, nämlich Gideon aus Lichtenberg. Hallo und guten Abend. Was war denn dein What the fuck Moment 2017, wenn es um Netzpolitik und zahlbar Kram geht?
Also ich denke, was mich auf jeden Fall sehr krass beschäftigt hat, war, dass ja einerseits die Piraten, die ja jetzt leider nicht mehr im Fenster sind, weil die sich leider verstritten haben, dass die eine sehr gute Netzpolitik gemacht hätten, hätten sie nicht sich in den anderen Punkten so den Hahn bekommen. Leider, leider. Ich bin mir ja gar nicht so sicher, hat die AfD nicht auch irgendwas mit Technik und sowas?
Also das glaube ich nicht, weil der Bundesverband Eko, also der Bundesverband, der Digitalbranche hat gerade gesagt, er wird nicht mit der AfD reden, obwohl jetzt im Bundestag sitzt, weil erstens haben die sich nicht ordentlich distanziert von dem rechten Gedankengut, was es da haufenweise gibt, und b, haben sie überhaupt keine fundierte Meinung zu irgendwelchen netzpolitischen Sachen.
Ah, okay, dann war das vielleicht die FDP?
Möglicherweise.
Ja, vielleicht, immerhin sind die ja jetzt reingekommen wieder. Also ich denke, wenn eine Partei im Bundestag oder so gewählt wird, dann hat sie gewissermaßen auch, je nachdem, wie sie gewählt wird, prozentuale Anrechte. Und es würde ich gewissermaßen auch geachtet zu werden. Auf was verratenweise auch immer. Aber egal, das war eigentlich nicht die Frage. Könntest du die Frage nochmal wiederholen?
Was war dein What the fuck bei meinem 2017?
Was ich auf jeden Fall nicht so krass fand, war die Wahlen. Die Wahlen waren einfach...
Warte, lass mich die Frage anders stellen. Warum hast du im Chaos Radio beim Chaos Computer Club angerufen?
Okay, also es war so, dass ich eigentlich mal wieder fritz hören wollte und dann dachte ich mir, ach, könnte ich jetzt mal wieder anrufen. Und dann habe ich gehört, oh Chaos Computer Club, interessant. Und dann, ja. Ehrlich gesagt habe ich erst angerufen und dann habe ich das Radio eingeschaltet, also mein M3 Player.
Okay, aber du hast jetzt noch sehr kurz Zeit dir auch ein Thema auszudenken, also dir einen Beitrag auszudenken, das auch mit unserem Thema zu tun hat. Weil das wäre uns schon sehr wichtig.
Ach so, das Thema war jetzt mit dem WhatsApp Moment oder war das ein Thema?
Naja, so generell das Jahr 2017 und was da so passiert ist in diesem digitalen Kontext.
Das Jahr 2017 im digitalen Kontext. Da waren zum Beispiel einige Videos auf YouTube über die Verbindung von Robotern und Menschen. Es ist ja gewissermaßen auch Digitalität, weil die ja immer mehr auch per Internet gestört werden.
Wie meinst du jetzt, dass Menschen tatsächlich künstliche Körperteile oder Hirnchips eingesetzt bekommen oder dass Roboter benutzt werden, um Menschen zu helfen oder dass Roboter Menschen ähnlicher werden?
Also dass Roboter benutzt werden, um Menschen zu helfen, finde ich gut. Aber sobald sie die Menschen irgendwann unterdrücken, und da sehe ich eine kleine Gefahr drin, keine große, aber eine kleine, da ist dann, da würde ich dann sehr vorsichtig sein.
Okay, dann müssen wir gleich hier die...
Wir sehen halt bei den ganzen Worten...
Lass doch mal genau hier die anwesenden Experten fragen. Also tatsächlich, was ja dieses Jahr tatsächlich viel kam, ist ja diese Frage nach der künstlichen Intelligenz und wie weit es ist und ob wir davor Angst haben müssen. Und das ist ja so was Ähnliches. Weil die roboterischste Maschine funktioniert ja nicht, wenn nicht ein Software drin ist, die sie selbst tätig oder selbstständig macht. Habt ihr Angst vor Säkularität?
Es gibt noch keine KI.
Wie hieß die nochmal von Microsoft? Seitdem hab ich nicht mehr so viel Angst davor.
Naja, Moment, also jetzt musst du erstmal beschreiben, was ist denn Tay?
Tay war eine sogenannte künstliche Intelligenz, die sie auf Twitter losgelassen haben.
In Form eines Chatbots.
Genau, da gab es halt so einen Bot, also so einen Twitter-Account, der sich halt mit Leuten unterhalten hat und in Twitter interagiert hat. Und das war halt nicht ein Mensch hinten dran, sondern das war ein künstliches Computerprogramm, das nicht intelligent war, glaube ich, von Microsoft.
Aber dass das sein sollte.
Dass es sein sollte und das ist dann...
Das hat durchaus gelernt.
Das hat halt nur so ein bisschen viel komische Dinge gelernt. Und ich glaube, am Ende haben sie sich abgeschaltet, weil das binnen wenigen Stunden ziemlich krass rassistisch geworden ist. Und das war, glaube ich, nicht so, was sie vorgesehen hatten.
Na ja, aber da ist ja die Frage, ist das wirklich ein Fehler der künstlichen Intelligenz, wenn Dean lernt, was man ihr beibringt?
Nein, also zum einen ist die gezielt getrollt worden.
Aber das ist halt genau der Punkt. Es ist halt nicht intelligent.
Es wird halt... Moment, also jetzt als Anwalt und Vertreter möglicher künstlicher Intelligenzen und vor allen Dingen ihren Selbstwertgefühl möchte ich an dieser Stelle sagen, wenn du ein kleines Kind nimmst und das in einem Nazi-Haushalt abgibst, was meinst du, was dann rauskommt? Und ja, ich habe jetzt Twitter mit einem Nazi-Haushalt verglichen. Also ich meine, im Ernst, also wie kann denn das der Anspruch sein? Das ist ja sozusagen...
Ich glaube, ich würde jetzt einfach mal unterstellen, dass halt mit, wenn man dieses Kind in diesem Nazi-Haushalt hat, dann wird das ja irgendwann mal den Rest der Welt kennenlernen. Und irgendwann gibt es eine Chance, dass das Kind das alles anfängt zu hinterfragen.
Aber das hatte ja Tay.
Tay hatte irgendwie einfach nur stumpf gelernt und hat sich dann halt an den Trolls orientiert und das Ganze ging dann ganz böse den Bach runter.
Tay ist wie jemand, der keine Ahnung von dem Thema hat, zuhört und dann so zwei, drei Wortfetzen aufschnappt und dann sagt der Lehrer, Herr Lehrer, ich weiß auch was, ich weiß auch was. Und dann einfach nur diese Wortfetzen paraphrasiert in der Menge oder in der Gewichtung, wie oft er sie gehört hat. So ganz grob.
Kann also nur nachplappern, aber nicht selber was Neues schaffen.
Also die wirkliche Leistung ist vielleicht noch die Gewichtung.
Das kommt durchaus wie ein Großteil der Menschheit vor.
Aber egal. Wir sind hier fürs Pistomisches.
Aber zurück zu dem, was Gideon gesagt hat. Nämlich die Vermischung oder das Andocken von Technik am Menschen.
Ich finde das so ganz krass. Also wieder auf den ersten Punkt. Der WTF-Moment mit dieser ganzen Überwachung hinzukommen. Ich habe letztens drüber siniert und dann ist mir aufgefallen, so in den 60er Jahren haben alle gesagt, so mit, ne, das erzähle ich hier nicht am Telefon, weil der Staat könnte ja mithören. Und heute so mit, na ja, ich pack mir da halt so ein Alexa oder so ein, wie heißt das Google Ding davon, so ein Google-Dot. Oder Home oder so.
Ey, ich hab jetzt... Wir können gerne noch mal gleich über Technik, die im Raum steht, mithören. Aber jetzt geht es ja gerade um Dinge, die in den Körper eingebaut werden.
Also sogar direkt in den Körper.
Also das ist ja tatsächlich so was, was immer mehr passiert.
Find ich cool.
Dass man technisch letztlich an... Also es gab zum Beispiel gefühlt dieses Jahr sehr viele so auch stylisch sehr geil aufbereitete Videos von Leuten, die irgendwie so Armprothesen tragen, die halt auch wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr gut funktionieren.
Also ich find's halt aus dem Medizin Aspekt ziemlich sehr abgefahren, was da möglich ist und das ermöglicht halt Leuten wieder Dinge zu erleben, das eigentlich nicht möglich wäre, wo man vor 20 Jahren gesagt hat so, nee, die Person kann definitiv nicht mehr laufen. Und dann gibt's da Möglichkeiten, wie solche Leute halt trotzdem auch wieder Marathon laufen können.
Also es ist halt einfach, weil die Technik so weit ist. Und nicht nur den ganzen Tag irgendwie in der Ecke sitzen müssen.
Und ich glaube, da ist im Prinzip, das einzige, worüber wir da reden müssen, ist Safety. Also sind diese Produkte wirklich sicher, diese Prothesen? Aber im Prinzip wird das ja immer noch von einem Menschen gesteuert. Das wird gesteuert von jemandem mit einem eigenen Willen. Und da würde ich das tatsächlich eher unter diesen Respektes, fängt der bionische Arm nicht irgendwie an, auf einmal wild um sich zu schlagen und alle Leute um sich herum zu bringen, weil leider jemand was falsch programmiert hat.
Habst du nicht erst letztens was mit irgendeinem Herzschrittmacher, der viel in den USA verbaut wurde, wo ganz viele Patienten relativ zügig bitte zum Firmware-Update kommen sollten, weil das sicher jetzt drin war?
Das war lange ein Problem. Die haben Bluetooth genommen, weil es ist billig und das gibt es überall. Dann kannst du es auch mit einer App konfigurieren oder der Arzt kann drauf zugreifen. Und das war alles nicht so richtig sicher. Deswegen gab es vor Jahren noch das Ding, ich glaube Dick Cheney war das, als er Vizepräsident war, hat das Ding eingebaut bekommen und hat eine Spezialversion ohne Drahtlosschnittstelle bekommen.
Also kann man dann auch so In-App Purchases machen für Wiederbelebung und sowas?
Ja, sie haben nur drei frei, die vierte kostet extra. Tatsächlich mehr Gedanken würde ich mir machen über diese selbst tötenden Maschinengewehrroboter, die an der koreanischen Grenze patrouillieren. Und dass wir halt da Geräte haben, die möglicherweise in dem Kontext selber Entscheidungen treffen, wann sie jetzt schießen und auf wen.
Aber das gibt es schon?
Das gibt es schon. Und ich mache mir jetzt weniger Gedanken über selbstfahrende Autos, die im Zweifelsfall in eine Wand fahren oder geringen Impact haben. Weil sie werden auf jeden Fall weniger Leute töten als ein Mensch, der gerade betrunken durch die Gegend fährt. Gedanken mache ich mir darum, dass so ein Roboter irgendwie durch die Gegend fährt und vielleicht sein Zielgebiet verlässt.
Aber ist es nicht generell sozusagen so, dass man sagt, man will eigentlich keine autonomen Waffen haben?
Könnte man meinen, aber sie machen Maschinengewehre an Drohnen dran.
Meine WTF-Momentliste ist gerade... Ich habe es einfach aus dem Gedächtnis verloren. Mir ist das immer noch über den Wickel.
Ich glaube, verloren nicht, das hat man gezielt ausgeblendet, weil man einfach denkt, das kann doch echt nicht sein.
Und ich glaube, es kommt auch nicht so wirklich in der Berichterstattung vor.
Nein, doch, es gab jetzt gerade ein virales Video von...
Von Boston Dynamics, meinst du?
Nein, nein, nein. Also es gibt diese Roboter... Nein, nein, von Autonomous Weapon, blablabla. Also wirklich so eine Vereinigung, die haben so ein Fake-Video gemacht, wie so ein Waffenproduzent, so hier, das ist die neue Mini-Drohne, die kann Gesichtserkennung. Der hat so eine kleine 3-Gammel-Explosiv-Ladung und dann schießt sie dir gezielt den Kopf kaputt und so. Und das ist ein Werbevideo für eine Organisation, die gegen autonome Waffen sozusagen vorgeht. Also da passiert schon was. Aber das ist...
Das ist schlimm, technisch geht das ja.
Was ich an dem Thema spannend finde, ist auch, eigentlich ist es ja eine total coole Vorstellung, weil man sagt, Zukunft werden Kriege so geführt, dass Roboter gegeneinander kämpfen.
Da kann man dann einfach nicht Krieg sein lassen und sagen, wir machen hier eine Simulation und danach zahlt jeder dem anderen Schadensgeld und dann war's das.
Eigentlich wäre das sozusagen genau das, was ich will. Und das ist dann aber sozusagen so wieder hinheeskaliert. Und dass es jetzt wirklich denkbar ist, dass wir Killer-Roboter im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes bekommen, das ist schon sehr, sehr, sehr gruselig. Ich will kurz Gido noch verabschieden. Wir sind ein bisschen abgewichen, aber ich hoffe, das hat dir zu dem Thema auch ein bisschen weitergeholfen. Gut.
Also ihr wollt jetzt sozusagen den nächsten Mal anholen.
Genau. Dann viel Spaß. Und natürlich 2018 sag ich schon mal. So, das wär das.
Und als Collectorial Damage vielleicht noch mal ganz kurz. Wenn jetzt gefordert wird, dass wir jetzt auch Cyberkrieg haben wollen, naja, wer sagt denn, dass da nicht zum Beispiel mal ein Krankenhaus runtergefahren wird und die Entsichtstation ausgeht?
Oder das Atomkaufwerk überhitzt.
Ja, ich mein, da kennen wir uns aus.
Ich hab noch eine Frage zu dem, also Dinge werden in Körper eingebaut, dann kann man schnell einen Marathon laufen. Jetzt haben wir gesehen, bei der Netzneutralität, also das Stream-on-Angebot der Telekom könnte man als ha ha, trojanisches Pferd, das ist dann auch gleich das nächste Thema noch, nehmen sozusagen, um das einzuführen. Die Gefahr bei diesem ganzen, wir werten den menschlichen Körper auf, ist ja auch, dass wir eine Gesellschaft schaffen, wo nur noch die Leute mitkommen, die sich so eine Dinge installieren, die sie besser, schneller, höher, weiter machen. Ist das auch eine Gefahr, die man jetzt...
Haben wir doch schon.
Na, ich kenn's jetzt von der anderen Seite eher, ich hab letztens mal wieder so eine Autofabrik angeschaut und da arbeiten Leute mit Exoskelett, was halt ganz praktisch ist, weil dann sind Leute, die ganz viel schwere körperliche Arbeit machen, wo man eigentlich noch keine Roboter einsetzen kann, aber in Zukunft, das halt einfach heißt, dass die Lebenserwartung nicht so hoch ist, oder man einfach sagt, du gehst in Rente und dann ist dein Körper so kaputt davon. Da kann man dank so einer Unterstützung, na, ein Exoskelett ist jetzt nicht im Körper, aber ist halt ziemlich nah am Körper und hilft dir dabei, unterstützt eine Maschine, den Körper sozusagen, dass man dann am Ende damit rumkommt und sagt, so der Körper wird nicht so belastet, also der Mensch wird nicht so kaputt gemacht dabei. Das ist halt auch was Positives manchmal.
Aber es ist auch so, egal was wir bauen, ist diese Zweiklassengesellschaft immer so weit fortgetrieben.
Ja, ich meine, die haben wir ja schon. Oder hast du mal geguckt, was du tun musst, meine Fotos zu eröffnen?
Er wird weiter fortgetrieben.
Und alleine, wenn man sich beobachtet, wie in einigen Bereichen gerade irgendwie die Dinge, wo man auf seinen Gehirn angewiesen ist, was da teilweise an Leistungsdoping betrieben wird, das ist zwar noch nicht mal körperlich, aber das gibt es halt durchaus auch. Und das ist jetzt schon ein Riesenproblem. Also die Frage, wie legitim ist das, dass man quasi gezwungen wird, um in einer Gesellschaft, wo man immer mehr leisten muss, Bestleistungen auch wirklich zwingend zu erbringen, egal in welcher körperlichen oder geistigen Verfassung man gerade ist. Das ist ja eine Debatte, die eigentlich schon jetzt läuft.
Brauchen wir am Ende doch Revolution? Darüber sprechen wir gleich. Jetzt gibt es erst mal Musik. Noch einmal von Ketsa mit Clips und danach den J-News. Danach geht's weiter hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Clips von Ketzer vom Album Firmament. Das ist die Netzmusik heute hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon, wo es nicht nur das gibt, sondern auch, wenn wir hier eigentlich gerade das ganze Jahr besprechen, auch mal die aktuellen Nerd News gibt, die geschrieben wurden von Mo und vorgetragen von Helena.
Intel Radeon. Intel hat für Anfang 2018 einen Prozessor mit integrierter Radeon Grafik angekündigt. Der Prozessor soll aus der achten Generation stammen und die Radeon Grafikeinheit direkt für den Einsatz auf Intel-Prozessoren entwickelt sein. Wahrscheinlich baut sie auf der Vega-Architektur auf. Bestätigt haben das bisher wieder Intel noch AMD. Hallo Magenta. Die Deutsche Telekom arbeitet an einem Sprachassistenten. Das berichtete Welt.de. Ein Sprecher des Unternehmens betonte, es werde Zeit für einen Assistenten, der konform zu deutschen Datenschutzgesetzen sei. Er soll Magenta-Assistent heißen und in einer Liga mit Amazons Alexa, Apples Siri und dem Google Assistant spielen. Ein Telekom-Lautsprecher soll ab Frühjahr für 150 Euro angeboten werden. Die Aktivierung erfolgt mit dem Spruch Hallo Magenta. CSU und SPD stellen Weichen für Windows in Münchner Verwaltung. Die Münchner CSU und SPD haben im Stadtrat die Weichen dafür gestellt, dass in der Verwaltung bis spätestens Ende 2020 rund 29.000 Rechner auf Windows umgestellt werden sollen. Im Büro sollen dann marktübliche Standardprodukte eingesetzt werden. Die Opposition kritisiert den Beschluss des Verwaltungsausschusses scharf als teuren Schildbürgerstreich, mit dem die Zeichen der Zeit verkannt würden. Der Beschluss sei inakzeptabel, da die Initiative entgegen dem ausdrücklichen Wunsch der Volksvertreter noch nicht durch externe Fachleute auf Wirtschaftlichkeit hin geprüft worden sei. ZITES-Präsident fordert Befugnisse zum Cyber-Gegenschlag. Der Chef der Entschlüsselungsbehörde des Bundes ZITES will die Sicherheitsbehörde bei Cyberangriffen zum Gegenschlag befähigen. Als Bürger erwarte er, dass der Staat auch bei neuartigen digitalen Bedrohungen handlungsfähig bleibe, sagte Wilfried Kahl, Präsident der Zentralen Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich, dem Nachrichtenmagazin Der Spiegel. Zum Hackerangriff auf den Bundestag 2015 wünscht sich Kahl, dass entwendete Dateien und Dokumente zumindest auf den Servern der Diebe gelöscht werden könnten. Abschaffung der Netzneutralität in den USA steht kurz bevor. Die Republikaner wollen die Netzneutralität abschaffen. Die Abstimmung in der zuständigen Regulierungsbehörde FCC ist für den 14. Dezember angesetzt. Im Gremium haben die Republikaner eine Mehrheit. Das zugrunde liegende Dokument heißt offiziell Restoring Internet Freedom Order. Es wurde auf der Webseite des FCC veröffentlicht und hat 210 Seiten.
Und ich habe mir vorgenommen, immer nach einer halben Stunde nach einem What the fuck Moment des Jahres zu fragen. Und da haben wir jetzt einen Anrufer, der das machen kann, das ist der André. Und dem André muss ich vorher mal was anderes fragen. Hallo André. Du bist ja aus dem Friedrichshain. Das ist ja quasi Minuten von hier entfernt, weil wir sind ja heute live aus dem Fräulein Fritz. Warum bist du nicht einfach vorbeigekommen?
Ja, ich habe es zu spät festgestellt, dass es da ist. Und ich sagte es vor kurzem auch über meine Matterhausaufgaben.
Ist ja auch kalt draußen. Ich würde ja auch nicht rausgehen wollen.
Du kannst doch jetzt nicht demotivieren, Mann.
Das schon, also.
Also, ich könnte den Spaziergang vertragen, ja, aber gut, also, aber Matterhausaufgaben lassen wir gelten.
Ja, das muss das muss sein für morgen.
Du hast einen WTF Moment mitgebracht. Was war der für dich?
Ja, der WTF Moment für mich war eigentlich dieses Jahr. Das war irgendwann im Sommer, kurz vor der Sommerpause, dass der Bundestrojaner als Trojaner durchgewinkt wurde. Ich glaube, das war bei der Autobahn Privatisierung oder bei der Autobahn Maut für PKWs. Da war der mit als Einhang dabei und kaum einer hat den gelesen. Der Gesetzesvorschlag ging durch und damit auch der Bundestrojaner. Das hat mich dermaßen angekotzt.
Habt ihr das noch verschirmen?
Ich glaube, dazu hatten wir noch eine PM rausgebracht, wo wir uns deutlichst empört haben.
Es fehlen einfach ein paar Polen im Agrarausschuss bei uns. Polen im Agrarausschuss. Auf EU-Ebene ist das Ding, glaube ich, mal gestoppt worden, weil die polnische Delegation im Agrarausschuss, wo es nachts durchgewunken werden sollte, gesagt hat, was hat das mit Agrarpolitik zu tun?
Nee.
Und jetzt haben wir hier so richtige Bundesprojekte?
Ja, schon.
Sie nennen es ja Quellen-TKÜ.
Aber André, anders gesagt, warum stört sich das denn? Warum war das ein What the fuck Moment? Hast du etwa etwas zu verbergen? Oder was hast du gegen den Bundestrojaner?
Ja klar hab ich was zu verbergen. Wer hat nichts zu verbergen? Ich hab meine Privatsphäre zu verbergen.
Hat dich das denn dazu geführt, dass du dieses Jahr dann irgendwie auch aufgestanden bist und aktiv geworden bist? Oder hat es dich sozusagen so gelähmt, dass du gesagt hast, was? Ich mach jetzt zu, du hast nur noch Mathe-Hausaufgaben.
Nein, ich wollte das eigentlich tun, aber ich hatte keinen gefunden und dann ging es dann auch halt zum Semesterarbeiten. Also da war ich dann noch nicht mal in Deutschland.
Oh, gleich ausreisen. Wenn der Bundesrat da kommt, da reisen wir gleich auf.
Wenn ich fertig bin, ja definitiv.
Wohin soll es dann gehen?
Das weiß ich noch nicht, wahrscheinlich ESA oder NASA.
Auch nicht schlecht.
Ich glaube die überwachen noch nicht so viel im Weltraum. Also ist das nicht die ganz gute Flugflugmöglichkeit von diesen Leuten.
Also sagen wir so, das was ich da machen möchte, hat ja auch nichts mit Überwachen zu tun. Das sind Terraforming-Projekte.
Aber man baut sich dann eine neue Erde und kann diese hier verlassen?
Ich will gerade sagen, ich finde das schon, ich finde es verständlicher als Reaktion, aber auch ein bisschen krasser zu sagen. Also nicht nur in Deutschland verlassen, sondern gleich die ganze Erde und dann einfach einen neuen Planeten formen, den dann möglicherweise unüberwachen. Aber sagt mal, liebe Expertinnen und Experten, warte, wir haben gar keine Experten, das ist auch so ein Problem, das sollten wir 2018 mal ändern. Es gab ja auch was so Überwachung von staatlicher Seite und Cyber-Cyber angeht. Noch ein anderes Thema, was wir da mal vorgekommen sind, nämlich CITES. Hast du das auch verfolgt, André? Das lassen wir uns jetzt erklären, was war CITES?
Die Zentrale Stelle für Informationstechnik im Sicherheitsbereich.
Das klingt voll gut, ne?
Das hast du abgelesen, oder?
Okay, dann lassen wir uns jetzt mal erklären. André, dir auf jeden Fall vielen Dank schon mal für deinen What the fuck Moment.
Ja wartet mal, dann komm ich doch noch vorbei.
Fräulein Fritz ist in der Falkensteinstraße am Schlesischen Tor.
Am Schlesischen Tor, aber das ist ja doch ein bisschen weiter weg.
Na komm on, jetzt einmal übern Fluss, in der Baumhausbar, also neben der Baumhausbar.
Hoxig in ihrem 10-Biss-Hogzug da.
Genau. Nicht, dass sie vorhin gerade irgendwie komplett lahmgelegt gewesen wäre, aber... Also André, wenn du willst, komm noch vorbei, wir würden uns freuen. So, CITES, was war das? Warum haben wir das und was erwartet uns da?
CITES, Cyber.
Ja, das ist eigentlich so ein tolles Ober-Cyber-Ministerium, das, glaube ich, sie haben gar nicht so genau gesagt, was es darf. Es darf nur mit allen zusammenarbeiten und darf so miniprinzipiell alles. Und man kann nicht genau sagen, was sie tun, aber sie dürfen trotzdem einfach mal alles machen.
Also was sie halt erkannt haben, sie da oben, TM, ist Spezialisten, die gewisse Aufgabe übernehmen können, die halt im Zusammenhang mit, ich möchte mal gerade gucken, was in diesen Daten drin steht, was in diesem Handy drin ist, wie auch immer. Die gibt es nur sehr beschränkt. Und die Lösung, die sie dann hatten, war, wir bauen eine zentrale Stelle, deswegen auch zentrale Stelle für Informationssicherheit im Sicherheitsbereich. Und das ist quasi ein Dienstleister für alle anderen Behörden im Sicherheitsbereich und löst zentral die Probleme, wo sonst jede einzelne Behörde einzelne Leute für brauchen würde.
Ein Cyberdienstleister, weil das sind dann, die die Ahnung von diesem ganzen Computerkram haben.
Dazu brauchen die auch jede Menge Fachleute, da gab es auch eine große Stellenausschreibung.
Genau, die haben so alles von ITlern, was es so gibt, aus allen möglichen Bereichen mal angefragt. Und dadurch, dass sie halt mit allen, dass sie so ein bisschen übergreifend sind, haben sie halt nicht wirklich so eine gewisse Einschränkung, soweit ich das lesen konnte, dass sie halt sagen, ihr dürft euch nur darum kümmern oder nur um Landessache oder Bundessache oder folgende Angelegenheiten, sondern eigentlich so mit, wenn ein Computer involviert ist, dürft ihr euch involvieren.
Okay, und diese Fachleute, haben die sich jetzt auch da zahlreich beworben? Weiß man das, ob es die deutsche innere Hacker-Armee schon gibt?
Also sie haben ja alles gegeben. Sie haben das in München angesiedelt. Sie haben das an der Bundeswehr-Uni angesiedelt. Also zumindest ist es da in derselben Location. Dann gab es aber, und das war auch eine unserer Nerd-News erst vor gar nicht so langer Zeit, ich glaube letztendlich vor letztem Monat, dass die ZITES-Eröffnung dann doch irgendwie abgesagt werden musste. Und offiziell war der Minister krank oder irgendwie sowas. Aber es verlautbarte, dass es möglicherweise auch etwas damit zu tun haben könnte, dass von den 120 Planstellen zu diesem Zeitpunkt leider nur 17 besetzt werden konnten.
Aber dann haben sie es outgesourced und einen Rahmenvertrag mit dem Chaos Computer Club abgeschlossen.
Das ist dann die Sorrentis Cyberwehr.
Wir hatten noch diese Krisen-Nummer von Demisier, die er haben wollte, und das haben wir dann damit reingepackt.
Und beim IT-Gipfel hat er irgendwie sowas gemacht.
Was ist nochmal langsam? Was? Krisen-Nummer? Chaos Computer Club? Was bitte?
Na, der Herr Demisier hat sich ja mal gewünscht, dass er eine Krisen-Nummer hat, dass wenn es eine Computer-Krise in Deutschland gibt, dann kann man da anrufen. Und dann gehen die Experten vom Chaos Computer Club dran und retten das Land.
Was hat der gesagt?
Ja, auf einer Bühne.
Aber ich mein, mal abgesehen davon, dass die Idee schon okay ist, aber der Imagewandel, den der Chaos Computer Club sozusagen durchgemacht hat, ist schon auch beachtlich, oder? Also ich mein, es war schon so, dass es Zeiten gab, wo der Chaos Computer Club eher so, das sind die komischen Leute, die auch eigentlich eher so Terroristen sind.
Ich bin mir im Nachhinein nicht sicher, ob das damals eine gute Idee war, dann doch einen EV zu gründen, nicht die Terrororganisation.
Also wir sind ein EV, weil man uns damals nahegelegt hat. Also wenn ihr euch nicht in kontrollierbare Strukturen begebt, dann könnten wir ja auf die Idee kommen, dass ihr möglicherweise eine Terrororganisation seid. Und seitdem gibt es den EV.
Okay, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist, der Imagewandel des Chaos Computer Clubs ist doch ganz okay eigentlich, oder nicht?
Ist okay, aber auf der anderen Seite sehen wir uns halt nicht als Dienstleister. Und das ist auch ganz, ganz, ganz fatal.
Natürlich, aber auf dieser Ebene, dass du sagen, ein Politiker, der wird es sicherlich, also man weiß es nicht genau, aber ich vermute, er hat das nicht ganz so ernst gemacht.
Am Ende holen die sich die Mitgliedsdaten von CCC und dann kommen die Feldjäger und holen die Leute ab und sagen, wir haben hier einen Cyberfall und wir müssen jetzt alle CCCler hier in einen Acker drücken.
Das war ja im Prinzip die erste Eskalationsstufe, das war zeitlich vor dem Cyberwehrvorschlag, wo es dann hieß, wir ziehen alle Sicherheits- also alle Leute, die-
Es gab tatsächlich die Idee in der Zwangsverpflichtung, das habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Nee, freiwillig. Also Firmen sollten freiwillig ihre Experten dem Land zur Verfügung stellen im Fall einer Cyberkrise.
Wow.
Dafür solltest du eine Freistellung vom Arbeitsvertrag und so geben und dann machst du Cyberabwehr.
Das klingt gut. Freut ihr euch schon?
Eigentlich nicht.
Wieso? Weil nein. Aber mal andersherum gefragt. Also als Mann für alle theoretischen Situationen kann man sich ja schon vorstellen, also gab es hier irgendwie einen Stromausfall dieses Jahr, der auf Hackdings irgendwie zu tun hatte?
Heizungsausfälle gab es wegen dem DINALOFT SERVICE, aber Stromausfall glaube ich, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Nein, es gab dieses Ding, es gab diese Ransomware, die auch Krankenkrankhaus irgendwie da Namen gelegt hat.
Das britische Gesundheitssystem und die dort angeschlossenen.
Genau, das war ja so. Das kann man sich ja durchaus auch noch eine Nummer größer vorstellen. Also nicht sozusagen Krankenhäuser, sondern alle Krankenhäuser.
Ja, aber in dem Fall wäre es halt mal interessant zu sehen, wie sie sowas überhaupt koordinieren wollen und was sie sich davon versprechen.
Aber das finde ich schon sehr selbstherrlich, sich als Hacker hinzusetzen, so ja die Krankenhäuser sind alle offline, jetzt gucken wir mal, wie ihr das koordiniert.
Das Ding ist ja nicht, dass wir seit Jahren vor genau den Gefahren, die ignoriert werden, warnen. Also wir warnen ja vor dieser grenzenlosen und unkonkretierten Vernetzung und davor, dass du den AKW 25.000 Remotezugänge für die Wartungsfirmen hast.
Ja schon, aber wenn es jetzt passieren würde, würde der euch dann hinsetzen und sagen, so nö, machen wir nicht. Wir haben es euch ja gesagt, für den Told you so Tanz auf der Asche.
Problem ist, du kannst da gar nicht viel machen. Du kannst die Sachen runterfahren, ausschalten und dann kann man mal sehen.
Wir hatten dieses Jahr am Chaosradio auch eine Sendung über, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie der Fachbegriff hieß, aber Leute, die sich professionell damit beschäftigen, was man tut, wenn Dinge passiert sind im eigenen Netzwerk. Und da ist schon ein bisschen Fachkompetenz da.
Durchaus, aber die machen halt auch erst mal nichts anderes, als wenn es zu spät ist, versuchen sie...
Ich fühle einen ausweichenden Antwort auf meine Frage.
Was machst du als Incident Response? Als Incident Response machst du Geräte vom Netz trennen, dafür sorgen, dass der Angrafer nicht weitermachen kann, schaltest die Sachen runter und fängst mit einem manuellen Notbetrieb an.
Na ja, genau, aber dazu brauchst du halt Leute, die das machen. Dann wäre die Frage, ist es nicht denkbar, also ist es nicht grundsätzlich eine gute Idee, dass man sagt, wenn sowas passiert, dann zieht man einfach alle Leute zusammen die Ahnung haben und versucht das dann zu nennen.
Du unterstellst aber, dass kriminelles Handeln das gleiche ist wie die Naturkatastrophe.
Ich unterstelle, dass es dieselben Auswirkungen hat und dass man dann als Mensch, der helfen kann, vielleicht eine moralische Verpflichtung hat, auch diese Hälfte zu geben.
Gehen wir davon aus, dass es wirklich ein großflächiger IT-Angriff ist und da sind jetzt irgendwelche Kraftwerker ausgefallen.
Ein Beispiel.
Die CCC Leute, wenn du die jetzt als IT-Experten siehst, haben keine Ahnung, wie man ein Kraftwerk manuell wieder hochfährt. Dafür gibt es dann Experten bei einem Kraftwerksbetreiber. Das Problem ist, dass du ohne IT-Unterstützung halt noch handlungsfähig sein musst. Und das kann man dann auch nicht mal eben in so einer Niveau wieder herstellen. Da musst du halt wirklich Handbetrieb machen und nach und nach die Sachen wieder ins Netz bringen und hochfahren. Da nützt es aber nichts, wenn jemand von außen kommt, der das System überhaupt nicht kennt.
Man kann auch jetzt nicht, natürlich kann es jetzt beliebig Fälle sozusagen konstruieren, wo man sagt, naja, da muss es aber auch, da muss es aber auch irgendwie analog gehen sozusagen. Aber es ist doch, es ist doch genauso gut denkbar, dass halt so ein Ding passiert, wo man sagt, das würde halt schon helfen.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Also wenn eine Krankenhaus-IT kaputt ist, dann musst du halt dafür sorgen, dass du ohne IT die Leute operierst und stabilisierst. Da gibt es andere Prioritäten, als das IT-System wieder hochzufahren.
Na ob das wirklich so ist, falls gerade ein Krankenhaus-IT-Lehrer zuhört, gerne anrufen. 0331 77 97 110. Bevor wir uns jetzt ganz in der Katastrophe verlieren, wollten wir, haben wir vorhin angekündigt, über ein anderes Thema sprechen, nämlich, ihr habt so kurz angedeutet, dass ihr nicht so ganz okay findet oder verwunderlich, dass sich Leute viel Technik ins Haus stellt, die ihnen zuhört. Ja, gerade das Internet of Things, Alexa's, Google Homes und Apple. Ach nee, Apple hat sein Produkt jetzt nochmal zurückgezogen, weil es doch nicht so geil war.
Siri? War das Siri?
Apple hat jetzt auch so einen Home-Lautsprecher mit Sprachsteuerungs-Dings irgendwie an den Start gebracht. Dann war das so, naja, lieber doch nicht, wir müssen das nochmal schön machen oder wie auch immer.
Also es ist halt interessant zu beobachten, wie schnell Widerstand bei Leuten einbricht, sobald ein gewisses Komfortversprechen da ist.
Das hat dann auch nicht mal funktioniert.
Es funktioniert so lange, bis jemand im Fernsehen Alexa sagt.
Ja, oder du hast dann dieses Versprechen mit dem Smart Home und der LED-Lampe, die dann irgendwie gestaltet wird und dann stellst du fest, ich sage, mach das Licht an und es dauert drei Sekunden oder fünf oder zehn, bis das Licht mal reagiert, weil das halt durchs Internet muss. Oder der Server vom Dienstleister ist weg und dann geht das Licht gar nicht mehr.
Was wir jetzt unlängst hatten, also gerade letztes Wochenende.
Von vorne.
Also du kannst dir Smart Home Komponenten kaufen und anstatt dass die, wie man sich das so einfach vorstellt, einfach bei dir lokal im Haushalt, sich untereinander unterhalten, laufen die aus, was weiß ich für Gründen, immer über den Server des Herstellers. Das bedeutet aber auch, dass wenn der Server oder dies war, war es ja nie einer. Es ist ja schon ein bisschen aufwendiger und nicht so leicht kaputt zu machen. Das wäre zumindest die Hoffnung, aber offensichtlich ist es passiert, dass die Infrastruktur dieses Herstellers komplett runtergefahren ist über das Wochenende.
Also es gab da ein Softwareupdate und dann konnten die nicht mehr miteinander reden.
Gab es dann noch eine Möglichkeit, die Lampe einfach ein- und auszuschalten?
Teilweise.
Sehr gut. Aber zurück zu diesem Alexa-Ding. Was ich ja ganz spannend finde, ist, da stehen jetzt in den Wohnungen Dinge rum, die hören ständig zu.
Genau, das machen sich ja auch viele nicht klar. Letztendlich hören die stets und immer zu, dass sie angeblich nur nach einem Activation-Wort, also nach einem Wort der Aktivierung irgendwie Alexa oder sonst irgendwas, tatsächlich anfangen erst, Sachen zur Interprestation in die Cloud zu schicken, heißt ja nicht, dass man, wenn man sich irgendeine Malware einfängt oder so, dass das Ding nicht tatsächlich dann permanent irgendwas wegschicken könnte oder so. Alleine die Tatsache.
Dass da eine mit dem Internet verbundenes Mikrofon in deinem Wohnzimmer und in deinem Schlafzimmer steht. Hier im RSC krapacht gerade jemand den schönen Spruch, wo smart draufsteht, steckt Überwachung drin. Der stimmt halt leider sehr. Also alles, was Sprachsteuerung macht, arbeitet momentan so, dass diese Sprachbefehle eben nicht auf dem Gerät lokal ausgewertet werden und erkannt werden, sondern die Audioschnipsel werden an einen Server geschickt, irgendwo im Internet, der analysiert. Und teilweise hören sich auch Menschen das danach noch mal an, um zu gucken, ob das richtig analysiert wurde.
Na, das ist eigentlich ein bisschen schade, weil wenn man so zurück überlegt, mal 10, 15 Jahre, da gab es irgendwie, was war das, ein Nokia 6310, glaube ich, und da konnte man schon mit Sprachsteuerung Leute anrufen.
Ja, oder bei IBM gab es...
Und das haben die alles auf einem ollen Telefon von vor 15 Jahren gemacht. Und da frage ich mich ein bisschen mit so, da steckt doch viel mehr CPU-Leistungen, also viel mehr Leistungen an Rechenleistungen, so ein kleiner Alexa-Ding. Und da kann man eigentlich viele, viele Befehle dort abfrühstücken, in wahrscheinlich genauso schnell wie das Internet ist, bis man da irgendwie einmal Daten zu einem großen in die Cloud schiebt und zurück.
Aber haltet ihr das wirklich für komplett ausgedacht? Was jetzt genau? Also ja, die Datentour zu bedenken, so kann ich nachvollziehen, und ich habe die selber auch. Aber haltet ihr komplett ausgedacht, dass man sagt, es ist schon unter dem technischen Gesichtspunkt einfach praktischer, das Ding irgendwie zentral zu machen, weil man dann die Systeme besser trainieren kann, weil man dann irgendwie besser werden kann, und weil man das sozusagen nicht lokal macht. Und dann einfach, also das lokal ist ja, dann stellt man das System dahin, dann muss es funktionieren, und dann macht man das nächste irgendwie.
Ich finde die Diskussion schwierig, weil sie im Moment rein theoretisch ist. Weil es gibt im Moment kein Projekt, das, oder es gab, komme ich jetzt gleich drauf, kein Projekt, das es anders gemacht hätte. Und das schickt sich jetzt Mozilla an zu ändern. Die haben das Projekt, ich glaube, Common Voice heißt es, gestartet. Das versucht eben genau das, dass die Sachen erst mal möglichst lange auf dem eigenen PC oder dem eigenen Handy stattfinden, was Spracherkennung angeht, und dass man dann quasi möglichst spät erst auf die Cloud zurückgreift, was zumindest datenschutzrechtlich deutlich entspannter sein könnte, je nachdem, wie sich dieses Projekt entwickelt. Und da wird man dann sehen, wie gut solche Systeme sind, obwohl sie möglicherweise nicht deine kompletten Sprachschnipsel in die Cloud transportieren. Die Cloud oder überhaupt dieses VoiceProjekt könnte ja auch durchaus von Dingen lernen, die jetzt nicht direkt die Sprachschnipsel übertragen.
Nämlich?
In dem Meta-Informationen, die eben nicht genau die Sprache wiedergeben, analysiert werden.
Das finde ich, das ist ja auch mal eine spannende Frage, die... Also das habe ich ganz oft. Bei mir ist der Beef, den ich immer mit Messenger habe. Es gibt ja Messenger, die sagen so, ja, also wir übertragen deine Kontaktdaten, aber wir machen das in einer total anonymisierten Form. Da geht es dann gar nicht so. Das selbe stelle ich mir auch bei diesen Sprachdingen. Würde ich mir auch fragen. Also ob ich mir jetzt ein Ding hinstelle, das meine Sprachschnitzel überträgt, oder ein Ding hinstelle, das überträgt Sachen, aber verspricht, dass das andere Sachen sind. Für mich als normaler Nutzer ist das ja überhaupt nicht kontrollierbar. Ich will ja entweder ein Ding haben, das mit Netz funktioniert oder ohne. Und ich möchte halt am liebsten haben, wo ich so ein Hardware-Schalter habe, wo ich sage, so Netz aus. Aber das ist illusorisch.
Ja, es gibt wenige Systeme, die sind noch fern von, na ja doch, sie sind benutzerfreundlich, aber es ist halt richtig viel Aufwand, das hinzubekommen. Zum Beispiel so ein Smart Home kann man sich auch komplett offline bauen. Das geht dann vielleicht nicht per Sprachsteuerung, oder kannst du unten von dem Display an der Tür jede einzelne Lampe im Haus schalten. Und das geht auch schon länger.
Das ist halt die bewährte Technik, die es schon immer gab. E-B, InstaBus, was es da so gab. Das ist halt nicht mit dem Internet verbunden.
Genau, das tut aber genau so, bis auf das irgendwie die Sprachsteuerung fehlt. Aber dann gibt es jetzt wieder neue Hausautomatisierungslösungen, wo dann alles über einen Server läuft. Wo es dann heißt, wenn der Hersteller tops geht, hast du worst case ein Haus mit ganz vielen Schaltern, was du nicht mehr bedienen kannst, weil der Server vom Hersteller ist irgendwann offline. Und das garantieren sie dir natürlich. Na ja, wir sind garantiert immer verfügbar die nächsten 10 Jahre, aber so ein Haus, das halt effiziert sicher.
Das finde ich auch so. Es ist auch in einem anderen Kontext, das ist eine große Rolle bei Computerspielen, es ist ja auch so, dass es mittlerweile viele Sachen gibt, die nur noch über Server funktionieren. Und ich frage mich schon, ob man nicht politisch aktiv werden sollte und sagen sollte, Leute, wir brauchen eine Gesetzgebung, gesagt, alle Dinge, die auf einer Serververbindung aufgebaut sind und verkauft werden, müssen auch eine Lösung anbieten, dass ich das Ding zu Hause betreiben kann.
Du hast ja schon ganz oft allein so simple Dinge, wie auch wenn du alles lokal hast, du musst ja nur zum, ist das auch wirklich dein Dizentskey, dich einloggen und dann sitzt du im Flieger und willst eine Runde Duddle nebenher und dann hast du kein Internet und dann so, tschu, dann hast du jetzt halt 8 Stunden vor dir, wo du nicht zocken kannst.
Ich würde gerne noch eine letzte Alexa-Frage stellen und das ist die, dass ich glaube, ich werde sozusagen spätestens nächstes Jahr ernsthaft anfangen, ein bisschen drüber nachzudenken, wie ich das mache, wenn ich in eine Wohnung komme, wo eine Alexa steht. Weil ich tatsächlich finde es selber für mich persönlich unvertretbar. Also ich möchte bei mir nicht so eine Dinge in der Wohnung haben. So und ich finde das so unvertretbar, dass ich eigentlich auch nicht in eine Wohnung gehen möchte, wo sowas drin ist. Habt ihr für euch schon mal drüber nachgedacht und eine Entscheidung getroffen? Sowas wie, okay, ich besuche dich, aber dann musst du bitte dein Alexa irgendwie vom Strom trennen? Oder ist euch das egal? Oder sagt ihr, okay, naja, dann musst du das abfügen? Also im Montag hast du zuerst gemeldet.
Ich wollte eigentlich noch dazu was sagen. Wir hatten die Diskussion auch schon mal im Chaosradio mit diesen Fernsehern, wo in der Anleitung dann jetzt drin steht, bitte diskutieren Sie keine vertraulichen Dinge vor Ihrem Fernseher, weil wir machen da Gesprächserkennung. Das war so ein Smart TV. Und ja, klar, du müsstest im Prinzip den Leuten sagen, macht das Ding aus und macht auch euren Google Assistenten auf dem Telefon aus, wenn wir über irgendwas reden wollen, was halbwegs vertraulich sein soll. Aber im Prinzip müsstest du eben das vorher schon machen, um die Leute zu erziehen und das Bewusstsein zu bauen.
Nee, aber ich möchte von euch persönlich wissen, geht euch das auch so? Und wenn ja, habt ihr schon überlegt, wie ihr das macht?
Noch nicht überlegt, weil ich bisher niemanden kenne, der so ein Ding so Hause rumstehen hat.
Ich hatte jetzt schon mehrfach Leute, wo es so ein Ding rumsteht. Und dann spricht man halt nicht über gewisse Dinge. Und teilweise bin ich dann auch so konfrontiert, die halt da mitten sagt so, ja, lass uns das doch irgendwie im CCB bereden und nicht hier mit Alexa.
Und wie ist denn die Reaktion?
Na ja, dann teilweise so mit, oh, ach so, ja, stimmt. Und dann zieht man halt den Stecker. Also dann halt so, da die Leute sind so dran gewöhnt, dass halt diese Bequemlichkeit da ist mit Alexa, spiele hier in der Fische und dann kann man wunderschöne Musik hören und da sind sie so...
Wie schnell das auch geht.
Und dann sind die so schnell und dann weist man sie mal wieder drauf hin, dass es halt doch so ein Einschnitt ist und dass sie ja doch alles mithören. Also, oh, ja, stimmt, hast ja recht. Stecker gezogen.
Ich finde es schon krass, wie schnell das geht, weil, also, Alexa ist so richtig erst dieses Jahr losgegangen, oder? Ja. Als Produkt, das gab es schon länger, aber so richtig quasi, dass es also so funktioniert.
Das fing ja an mit Siri so ein bisschen und OK Google und wie es alles heißt. Und dann irgendwann so, naja, dann kann man es ja auch fest zu Hause hinstellen.
Ist das eigentlich OK Google Format C? Na, ist Festplatten gelöscht bei den Leuten, die zuhören?
Ruf uns an unter 0331 70 97 100, wenn gerade eure Festplatte gelöscht wird oder wenn ihr ein extra zu Hause stehen habt, weil mit so jemand würde ich eigentlich auch gerne mal reden, um es nachzufangen, weil letztlich kenne ich selber auch noch keinen. Ich gehe nur davon aus, dass mir es früher später beginnen wird.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, spiele Fritz, aber funktioniert so auch.
Sehr gut. Wir hören jetzt hier noch ein bisschen Musik von Ketzer. Wild Plains heißt der nächste Track. Danach Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr und danach sind wir wieder da.
Kommt endlich mal wieder in diese einzigartige Stadt. Da versprechen wir euch doch mal ein einzigartiges Konzert.
Jetzt präsentiert...
Montag, 5. März.
Bundespräsident Steinmeier versucht weiter, neue Wahlen zu verhindern und eine Regierungsbildung in Gang zu bringen. Am Abend hat er dazu die Chefs von CDU, CSU und SPD im Schloss Bellevue empfangen. Was genau besprochen wurde, ist nicht bekannt. Die Vorsitzenden wollen morgen erst ihre Parteikremien informieren. Ausminister Gabriel von der SPD sieht bei der Regierungsbildung keinen Zeitdruck. Niemand dürfe erwarten, dass das schnell gehe, hat er im ZDF gesagt. In der AfD bahnt sich möglicherweise ein neuer Machtkampf an. Nach ARD-Informationen denkt der AfD-Fraktionschef im Bundestag Gauland darüber nach, für den Parteivorsitz zu kandidieren. Damit könnte es auf dem Bundesparteitag an diesem Wochenende zu einer Kampfabstimmung kommen. Der Berliner Landeschef Basterski hat nämlich schon Anfang der Woche erklärt, dass er AfD-Chef werden will. Er gilt als Vertreter des gemäßigteren Flügels in der Partei. Der amtierende Parteichef Meuthen will ebenfalls wieder antreten. Die Berliner CDU wirft dem rot-rot-grünen Senat Versagen beim neuen Flughafen BER vor. Die letzten Berichte über Mängel und Risiken zeigten, dass der Senat seiner Verantwortung nicht gerecht werde, sagte CDU-Generalsekretär Evers im Abgeordnetenhaus. Auch Vertreter der Koalition äußerten sich in der Debatte besorgt, beim BER gibt es offenbar immer noch Probleme beim Brandschutz. Das steht in einem TÜV-Bericht, der vor kurzem bekannt geworden ist. Die Argentinische Marine stellt die Suche nach möglichen Überlebenden in einem verschollenen U-Boot ein. Es gehe nun nur noch darum, das Schiff zu finden und nicht mehr um die Rettung der Crew, sagte ein Sprecher der Marine. Der Kontakt zu dem U-Boot war am 15. November abgebrochen. 44 Besatzungsmitglieder waren an Bord. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin-Köpenick sind es Null und in Charlottenburg ein Grad. Neuglobse und Ludwigsfelde melden Null, Eberswalde und Forst ein Grad. Es ist noch meistens trocken und nur wenig bewölkt. Nach und nach kann es aber von Nordosten erste Schneeregen oder auch Schneeschauer geben. Passt dann bitte auf, da kann es glatt werden. Auf 0 bis minus 3 Grad gehen die Temperaturen im Laufe der Nacht runter. Morgen ist es meistens dicht bewölkt und von Nordosten ziehen immer wieder Schnee und Schneeregen durch. Am Nachmittag erreichen die Schauer dann auch den Flaming und die Niederlausitz. 1 bis 4 Grad sind an Höchsttemperaturen drin. Stadtverkehr Berlin in Weißensee ist die Buschallee zwischen Hansa-Straße und Suomonsstraße in Richtung Althohen Schönhausen gesperrt. Grund ist dann Wasserrohrbruch und zur S75. Wegen einer Weichenstörung kam im Ostbahnhof, fahren die Züge weiterhin nur zwischen Wartenberg und Ostkreuz. Da, wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des AirBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de und in der Fritz App. Und das Auge hört mit, Mann.
Das Chaosradio hat noch eine halbe Stunde. Herzlich willkommen zurück, frabe Stanimon. Moin, Tagstar. Und wir sprechen hier über das Jahr 2017 und was so passiert ist. Und wir haben gerade über die ganzen Dinge gesprochen. Da nehm ich ganz kurz durch das Mikrofon. Sagt doch mal was. Hallo? Na siehst du, geht doch. Und wir haben ein sehr schönes Studio Message erhalten. Man muss davor, bevor ich die vorlese, noch kurz erklären, was Dash-Buttons sind. Amazon hat so Buttons, die kann man zu Hause installieren. Und wenn man die drückt, dann wird automatisch eine Kauf ausgelöst. Zum Beispiel, wenn man so die Idee ist, man klebt sich auf die Waschmaschine, wenn das Waschmittel alle ist, zack. Weil er schreibt jetzt, wenn er irgendwo einen Alexa sieht, dann setzt er Babyrassel und Penispumper auf die Einkaufsliste, Fram the Dash-Buttons drückt er aus Prinzip mehrmals. Dann noch schnell die Raumtemperatur auf 50 Grad gesetzt, die Jalousien auf Endlosschleife, Heavy Metal auf die Playlist für 6 Uhr morgens und den Nervenzusammenbruch des Hausbesitzers auf YouTube gestreamt. Ein gelungener Abend. Vielen Dank dafür, Ronje. Also vielleicht können wir doch ganz dankbar sein über die Technifizierung, zumindest fremder Haushalte, weil sie jede Menge Spaßpotenzial haben.
Das kommt drauf an, was dir an deinen Freunden liegt, ne?
Naja, wenn sie eine Alexa im Raum haben, geht es ja auch darum, sozusagen ein Statement abzugeben und wenn argumentative Argumente, die Argument enthalten, nicht helfen, dann vielleicht Heavy Metal X-O-Mogues.
Gibt es denn nicht so Alexa-Kondome?
So, so...
Naja, wahrscheinlich wird es schon irgendwann sein, dass sie auch Spracherkennung haben, dass dann nicht jeder irgendwie herkommen kann und sagen kann, Alexa. Apropos, das wollte ich noch fragen, Gesichtserkennung.
Ja, ganz große Mode.
Also die gibt es ja genau, die gibt es ja schon eine Weile, aber jetzt ist es wieder so eine, nachdem Apple das auch macht, sprechen jetzt auch mal alle drüber und die ich frage, ich frage nicht, warte, ne frage ich ob das ne ich frage, wann wird die kaputt gemacht? Ja. Also ist doch schon. Entschuldigung?
Also es gibt doch jetzt schon Masken.
War das nicht ein Fake oder haben die jetzt nur was ordentliches rausgebracht, wo man sah, dass es doch gar...
Das weiß man glaube ich noch nicht so ganz.
Also können wir nicht mal kurz anrufen?
Diese ganze Gesamte Gesichtserkennung hyped gerade irgendwie ganz heftig. Wir haben am Bahnhof Südkreuz Gesichtserkennung, um irgendwelche bösen Leute zu erkennen. In Apotheken wird es benutzt, um die Besucher nach Alter und Geschlecht zu... Bayer hat das gerade zurückziehen müssen, genauso wie es ja in Supermärkten versucht wurde. Es gibt so Werbetafeln und in der Werbetafel ist eine kleine Kamera, die filmt, wer vor der Werbetafel stehen bleibt.
In einer Apotheke?
Ja genau, das haben sie in Supermärkten versucht, da kam es nicht gut an und dann hat Bayer das in der Apotheke versucht, um rauszukriegen, wie alt sind die, in welches Geschlecht und was können wir da besser als Werbung machen. Wie lange gucken sich die Werbung überhaupt an?
Bitte guckt jetzt auf media.ccc.de, die Über-Tragung an Video Livestream und ihr seht mich jetzt an Facebook. Ja bitte, so in der Apotheke.
Das haben sie dann auch irgendwann eingesehen, dass das keine gute Idee war, aber wir haben das halt in Supermärkten, Apotheken, Bahnhöfen. Und in Australien gibt es jetzt ein Public-Private-Partnership, wo du, wenn du zum Beispiel Webseitenbetreiber bist und jetzt rauskriegen möchtest, ob der Mensch, der da vor der Webseite ist, wirklich derjenige ist, für den er sich ausgibt mit dem Account und so, kannst du ein Bild von der Person an diesen Dienst von der Regierung schicken, also das Bild mit den vermuteten Namen von den Menschen, den er eingegeben hat und die sagen dann, jo, der Name passt.
Weil die das von den biometrischen Fotos, die die mit dem Ausweis haben?
Genau.
Na gut, in Australien kannst du auch dein Nacktbild bei Facebook hochladen, damit sie dann zukünftig Nacktbilder von dir erkennen können.
Damit du Revenge-Porn verhinderst, schickst du Nacktbilder von dir an Facebook, damit sie daraus ein Hashbild, damit das nicht mehr anderes hochladen kann. Und, und, und, ein Mensch guckt sich das Bild an, um zu begutachten, ob es wirklich ein Nacktbild ist.
Gab es darüber Statistiken, wie viele Leute das gemacht haben auch wirklich?
Nee, das finde ich wirklich dramatisch.
Also ich finde es ja einerseits so krass, dass ein Konzern das macht. Aber ich würde gerne sehen, wie viele Leute das machen.
Ich frag mich, wie viele Bewerber sie bekommen haben.
Da fängt man glaube ich an einer Stelle an, sich über Menschen lustig zu machen, die nicht so okay sind. Weil ich finde das unfassbar in dieser Stelle, nur die Firma. Weil stell dir vor, du bist jemand, dem solche Fotos weggekommen sind. Und dann ist das deine nächste Möglichkeit. Du solltest es ja vorher da machen. Nein, darum geht es nicht. Es geht ja da wie vorher.
Du sollst die Bilder von dir da hinschicken, um zu verhindern, dass jemand sie veröffentlicht.
Ja, genau, aber niemand macht nackte Fotos, legt sie dann sofort raus. Die Idee ist ja dieses, ich habe jemanden im Verdacht, der wird das im nächsten tun, und dann macht man das. Das ist aus der Notlage diesen Impuls.
Ich kann die Verzweiflung und die Panik da sehr gut nachvollziehen, dass man dann alles versucht, um das zu verhindern.
Genau, und dann wird durch so ein Ding quasi so ein Vertrauen in diese Firma und die Technologie.
Das ist ekelhaft. Ich möchte mich wachen. Ich finde es krass, dass die Firma das Vertrauen missbraucht. Und wie es halt andererseits auch, wie man es davon ausgeht, dass Facebook nichts Böses will zum Beispiel. Und dass man da vor mehreren Jahren hat, dass man immer noch kritisch hinterfragt.
Die einzige Möglichkeit, sicher zu sein, ist sich noch mehr zu umblößen. Sehr schön. Da komme ich gleich zum nächsten Thema. Ich habe es nicht genau verstanden. Ich habe mir in die Vorbereitung der Datenreichtum reingeschrieben. Und jetzt denke ich bei allem von dem, was ihr jetzt schon in den letzten 90 Minuten kaputt gemacht habt, denke ich, der Datenreichtum ist böse. Aber das ist nicht ganz so.
Ich suche gerade die Notizen. Also Anlass war zum Beispiel, dass wir jetzt gerade wieder ein Datenreichtum hatten bei einem Fahrradverleihert, der auch in Berlin aktiv ist.
Was genau meinst du denn mit dem Begriff Datenreichtum?
Du meinst jemanden, der viel zu viele Daten sammelt, die man eigentlich nicht braucht und dann kommen sie platziert an.
Genau, so Gesichtserkennung, Vorratsleitspeicherung.
Also ganz kurz, der Begriff des Datenreichtums kommt daher, dass damals, ich glaube, es war sogar unsere Bundeskanzlerin vor nicht allzu langer Zeit mal gesagt hat, Daten sind das Gold des 21. Jahrhunderts. Man sollte doch Daten sammeln als etwas Positives sehen. Und in dem Zusammenhang wurde halt der Begriff Datenreichtum euphemistisch dafür verwendet, wenn immer einem Unternehmen Daten abhandengekommen sind und immer besonders auch dann, wenn man irgendwie sehen konnte, dass das vielleicht doch nicht so eine tolle Sache ist, dass diese Daten abhandengekommen sind.
Aber ist ja auch eigentlich auch geil, wenn man Datenreichtum sagt, kann man auch dieses Bild von dem Jolly Pirate, der sozusagen lustig, krakälend die Schatzkiste aus dem Ding rausträgt.
Ja und vor allem diese Datenschützer blockieren dann das mit diesem Reichtum, deswegen nerven die und müssen weg.
Okay, also es ist doch ein schlechtes Wort, also sozusagen ein Begriff, wo man sagt, da will man eigentlich wenige davon.
Ja, also Datenreichtum heißt halt, dass die Daten plötzlich öffentlich verfügbar sind, also zumindest in der Verwendung, wie wir das hier so machen.
Ich finde, wir sollten irgendwann noch mal eine Sendung machen, wo wir tatsächlich mal über die Chancen von Technik sprechen, weil das, also sagen, das macht ja schon Dinge auch möglich. Also ich mein, also ja, es ist gefällig, aber es macht, also das soll man vielleicht nicht vergessen, aber weil wir bald schon wieder am Ende sind, wir wollten ja noch über was anderes reden, was in Zukunft ansteht.
Du meinst diesen Kongress, diesen Chaos Communication Kongress.
Also ich will vorher noch mal fragen, so das Jahr 2007 zusammengefasst, würde man das noch mal so wollen oder was wünschen für das nächste Jahr?
Ich würde die Simulation gerne beim letzten Safe Point noch mal starten.
Wann ist der?
Vor Trump.
Also ich glaube, wir waren uns vor der Sendung ganz einig, dass diese Theorie, dass wir alle in einem absurden Universum, das gerade noch übrig geblieben ist, nachdem irgendein Unfall am NLC passiert ist und dass wir gerne irgendwie zurück wollten zu diesem Punkt, bevor dieser Unfall passiert ist und uns dann ein Universum suchen, in dem diese ganze kaputte Sachen nicht passiert sind. Das hätten wir gerne.
Können wir es einfach nicht schlimmer machen?
Schlimmer geht immer.
Danke.
Fakt doch sowas nicht.
Nicht lächelt und war froh und es kam schlimmer.
Aber immerhin, bevor die Welt untergeht, gibt es mal Chaos Communication Congress. Also hoffen wir alle, dass es noch so lange hält. Ist nur ein Monat, aber man weiß ja nie.
Ein Kongresszentrum haben wir schon ruiniert.
Das ist ja Hamburg. Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, der ist ja in Leipzig.
Genau.
Die wichtigste Frage, die jede Hörerin, jede Hörer sofort hat, wenn es um den Chaos Communication Congress geht, ist gibt es noch Tickets?
Nein?
Nein. Keine Tickets mehr?
Ja.
Aber war nicht erst eine Tickets verkaufswelle?
Nein. Alle drei sind durch, alle Tickets sind weg und es gibt aber noch auf events.ccc.de im Wiki, wenn ihr euch da ein bisschen durchklickt, da gibt es eine Ticketbörse. Die Idee ist, dass da auch so ein bisschen drauf geguckt wird, dass jetzt niemand anfängt, da den Wucher aufzurufen, sondern dass wirklich Leute, die merken, oh, keine Ahnung, vielleicht sollte ich doch lieber bei der Abtante vorbeischauen bei Weihnachten, anstatt auf diesen Kongress zu gehen, dann ihr Ticket abgeben und dass man dann vielleicht noch eine Möglichkeit hat, Tickets, die ja meistens dann auch mit Hotelbuchungen einhergehen, zu erwerben und dann vielleicht doch noch auf diesen Kongress zu kommen.
Jetzt ist ja heute das Engelsystem, das sogenannte online gegangen und Engel sind ja die Helfer, die auf dem Kongress mithelfen. Es ist aber nicht so, wenn man sich da eintritt, kann man nach Hause machen, die Chance zu kommen, sondern das sind auch Leute, die ihr schon ein Ticket haben.
Ja, genau. Also das kann man auch nur jedem empfehlen, der auf dem Kongress ist. Wenn ihr nicht einfach nur Vorträge hören wollt, das könnt ihr nämlich auch irgendwie von zu Hause, vom Bildschirm, macht mal eine Engelschicht, probiert mal aus. Ihr trefft eine Menge interessante Leute und lernt eine Menge.
Vor allem sieht man Seiten vom Kongress, die man eigentlich nie sehen kann. Damit erlebt man den Kongress erst richtig, weil es ja entsteht ja nur darauf, dass ganz viele Leute mit anpacken und das macht richtig geistig.
Und man konsumiert eben nicht nur, sondern wird selber aktiv und ansonsten Chaos-Party-innen und Chaos-Party-innen.
Genau, das auch.
Das sind die Menschen, die Menschen an die Hand nehmen, die zum ersten Mal auf den Kongress sind.
Genau, wenn es dein erster Kongress ist, und du nicht unsicher bist oder irgendwo einfach nur Leute kennenlernen willst, mit denen du halt über den Kongress ziehen kannst, dann ist das eine gute Anlaufstelle, wenn es dann erst mal beim Kongress ist.
Wie ist es denn bei euch? Was macht ihr denn? Welche hälfte Funktion macht ihr denn auf dem Kongress?
Mal gucken.
Internet.
Und ich werde wieder mithelfen, dass ihr alle zu Hause bleiben könnt und Videos gucken könnt.
Ich bringe ihm dann immer wieder was ans Mischpult.
Auch das muss erledigt werden. Wird es, weil wir hier im Radio sind, eine Podcastbühne geben, wie es die Jahre davor gab?
Dieses Jahr ja nicht, es wird aber voraussichtlich eine Podcast Assembly geben, das heißt zumindest Audio wird es sehr wahrscheinlich in irgendeiner Form geben.
Okay, aber nicht quasi diesen eigenen Raum, wo man mit Publikum Dinge tun kann?
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Und deswegen ist das wahrscheinlich dieses Jahr auch unser letztes Chaosradio. Richtig?
Wie für immer?
Nein, dieses Jahr.
Okay, gut, also falls es ein Sendungszentrum geben wird, gäbe es unter Umständen noch ein Chaosradio. Aber okay, kommen wir zum Vortragsprogramm. Ich habe, es gibt ja dieses Halfnab, das ist auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, da könnt ihr auch mithelfen. Es gibt eine Vorabwesung des Vortragsprogramms online, das heißt Halfnab und da stehen nicht drin, wann die Vorträge laufen, sondern da steht drin, welche Vorträge es gibt. Und dann könnt ihr anklicken, was euch interessiert und daraus wird dann der Zeitplan gebastelt mit der Hoffnung, dass dann möglichst wenige Vorträge, die dieselben Leute interessieren, parallel laufen. Also dass selten vorkommt, dass ihr der Vorsitzende sagt, oh nein, meine beiden allergeilsten Vorträge laufen parallel, dass das nicht passiert, das könnt ihr helfen, indem ihr jetzt dahin geht und das schon mal ausfüllt. Ich habe da schon mal reingeguckt und habe einen Vortrag gesehen, der mich sehr interessiert hat. Und zwar da geht es darum, dass wir die Digitalisierung anbeten wie etwas göttliches. Gefällt mir alleine schon das Bild, mit dem Computer umzugehen wie mit einem Gott oder will denn jemand drüber sprechen, dass er sagt, naja, also momentan schreiben wir dem Digitalen so eine allmächtige Omnipotenz zu, dass wir alle Probleme lassen, sich damit lösen und der will mal sagen, was denn wirklich jetzt der Stande sind, wo man vielleicht damit leben kann und vielleicht wo es nichts bringt.
Das hatten wir schon mal unter dem Begriff Elektronenhirn. Da gab es das schon mal, dass man sagt, das wird dann alles besser und dann fliegen wir zum Mars.
Naja, aber ich glaube, das haben wir Socialbots. Also Elektronen ist ja sozusagen, na gut, wir werden sehen, was ist, was findet ihr im Programm interessant? Was hat euch da sozusagen, was sind eure Highlights? Was wollt ihr hier schon mal zum Besten geben?
Na, zum einen ganz kurz, wir hatten ja vorhin über diese Mikrofone gesprochen im Kabel. Da geht es einen Vortrag zu über versteckte Überwachungstechnologie. Und ansonsten finde ich mal ganz spannend, so ein bisschen zu gucken, wie war das eigentlich, bevor ich im Internet war? Es gibt da irgendwie Vorträge zu BBSen, also das heißt zu Mailbox-Systemen. Das war zum Beispiel lange vor meiner Zeit. Dann natürlich wieder Security Nightmares.
Ich habe mir so einen Vortrag rausgesucht, der heißt Null und Einsen auf dem Acker. Und da geht es tatsächlich darum, wie diese Digitalisierung Einzug in die Agrarwirtschaft nimmt. Und das finde ich, ist eigentlich sowas, was man partout nicht auf dem Schirm hat. Aber ich finde, das klingt erst mal total interessant.
Das stimmt, das habe ich auch gesehen. Das ist ja wirklich so, also das ist ja etwas, was man, die es nicht auf dem Schirm haben. Und da ist ja autonomes Fahren schon.
Ja, ich habe es schon mal am Augenwinkel aufgenommen, aber das ist dann so. Aber das halt mal von jemandem, der wirklich tief drin steckt zu hören, klingt glaube ich sehr spannend, weil irgendwie, ja, man hat schon so ein ziemlich aufgebautes Navi in so einem Traktor drin, dass der eigentlich fast autonom fährt, also nur jemand Gas geben muss, damit er rollt.
Genau, das Problem ist, dass sie Karten dazu brauchen, wo alle Strommasten zum Beispiel drauf sind, die in ihrem Feld stecken. Und es gab wohl mal ein Inzident, dass dann so ein Trecker so eine Strommast umgefahren hat. Seitdem dürfen sie nicht mehr komplett autonom.
Und ich glaube, da wird man dann im Vortrag drüber hören oder nicht spoilern.
Genau, das hat mir ein Landwirt vor ein paar Jahren erzählt.
Ich frage mich auch, ob wir noch was dazu hören würden, was auch dieses Jahr, so können wir im Rückblick noch sagen, herumging, ist, dass es im Agrarmarkt einen reichhaltigen Schwarzmarkt gibt für Hacking-Tools für Ersatzteile.
Das hatte ich auch gelesen.
Weil Ersatzteile, die in Trecker eingebaut sind, werden sozusagen über einen Computer lizensiert und dann macht man das so als Ersatzteil.
Da war dann noch der Haken, dass man die passenden Ersatzteile nicht mal wirklich schnell genug hinbekommt, weil das dann irgendwie eine Farm mitten in Amerika ist, wo man jetzt nicht so schnell mal eben von aus Deutschland oder so was, oder England, passende Ersatzteile mit Techniker hinbekommt und dann gab es da einen Schwarzmarkt wohl, wo man dann doch mal innerhalb von ein paar Stunden das passende Ding hinbekommt, aber...
Landwirte sind halt gewohnt, ihre Maschinen selbst zu reparieren und die Hersteller möchten natürlich da jetzt ein Geschäft draus machen.
Aber vielleicht werden dann Landwirte irgendwann die besseren Programmierer, weil sie sozusagen so trainiert darin sind.
Auf jeden Fall werden sie trainiert.
Oder sind die Leute, die uns in der Revolution helfen, weil sie wiederum die Technik überall drin überlisten können.
Die einzigen, die Killer-Roboter überwachen können.
Abschalten. Aber was gibt's noch? Was ich ganz spannend finde, wir haben dieses Jahr das erste Mal einen kompletten Track der sich mit Resilienz beschäftigt, also mit Widerstandsfähigkeit. Wie widerstandsfähig ist Software, wie widerstandsfähig ist Hardware? Und wie kann man widerstandsfähige Hardware produzieren, die gegen gewisse Fehler nicht anfällig ist, die direkt so designt ist, dass man nicht sagt, ach ich kloppe da mal ein Programm hin und das wird schon irgendwie laufen, sondern dass man sich von Anfang an mal überlegt, wie programmiere ich das denn? Und welche technischen Ansätze wähle ich, dass möglichst wenig Fehler passieren? Und dann gibt es andere Vorträge, die überlegen sich, okay, ich kann zwar irgendwie sogar mathematisch beweisen, dass ein Programm genau das tut, was es tun soll, nur gehe ich denn von den richtigen Annahmen aus, wenn ich diese mathematischen Beweise aufstelle? Das ist also ein wirklich komplexes Feld, aber eins, das bisher viel zu wenig beleuchtet ist und das wirklich dazu führen könnte, dass wenn man da wirklich mal eine Debatte.
Ich muss dich kurz umbringen, du hast Montags erzählt, es gibt eine Art Dinge zu hacken, die man immer in einem Hollywood-Film sieht, wo man denkt, so ein Quatsch, die jetzt aber echt ist.
Naja, wir hatten in den letzten Jahren eine ganze Reihe Sicherheitslücken, die sich zum Beispiel auf WLAN und Bluetooth bezogen, aber eben nicht auf die Software, die auf dem Handy läuft, sondern auf die Software, die in den Chips läuft, die in den Handys eingebaut sind. Das heißt, ich habe Bluetooth aktiviert auf meinem Handy und im Vorbeigehen kann jemand den Bluetooth-Chip in meinem Handy umprogrammieren und damit Code auf meinem Handy ausführt und Sicherheitslücken im Handy auslösen.
Wie wir jetzt im Vorbeigehen?
Also per Funk, drahtlos.
Naja, beim Vorbeigehen auch, was die Zeitspanne angeht, also so innerhalb weniger Sekunden oder?
Ja, man kann ja mal daneben stehen für ein paar Sekunden, aber schon.
U-Bahn reicht ja auch.
U-Bahn reicht. Also solange irgendwie ich stehe mit jemandem für eine Station in der U-Bahn, ein glaubhaftes Eingriffsszenario und Bluetooth funktioniert jetzt nicht nur, wenn ich, wenn ich Körper an Körper mit jemandem stehe, sondern es reicht jetzt, dass ich wegen demselben Waggon bin. Und das, also man muss sich das halt im Klaren machen. Es geht nicht unbedingt darum, dass man mit dem Menschen jetzt wirklich dicht an dicht stehen muss. Das ist gar nicht notwendig.
Gibt es auch Bluetooth-Kondome? Oh Gott, dass ich überhaupt noch technische Geräte benutze und ich mittlerweile angefangen hab.
Oh, im IRC kommt auch gerade IME. Es gab ja auch die Intel Management Engine, die in modernen Notebooks zum Beispiel drin ist, wo man dann per Netzwerk auf einen Management Prozessor zugreifen kann, der im Notebook eingebaut ist und der auch läuft, wenn das Notebook sonst aus ist.
Ja, also du hast...
Warte mal, mein Notebook hat eine Komponente, die an ist, wenn es aus ist?
Ja.
Du willst ja das BIOS updaten können, wenn das Ding aus ist in der Firma.
Oder du möchtest als Systemadministrator von all deinen Schäfchen auf den Rechner und irgendwie Windows updaten können und tralala. Und irgendwie Remote Services, wenn der sein Rechner ganz doll verfickelt hat.
Da war auch eine Sicherheitszocke drin oder was?
Genau. Und zwar das Ding, diese Software darf alles. Stell dir vor, du hast ein Stück Software, das läuft aus einem Betriebssystem. Das Betriebssystem darf im Prinzip schon alles. Dieses Betriebssystem ist im Chip und darf noch mal mehr. Und das läuft und hört auf den Netzwerkport und viel Spaß.
Okay, möchten wir dann ganz zum Schluss noch mal über das sprechen, was alle gesprochen haben, über Apple?
Ja, Apple schickt sich gerade an. Apple schickt sich gerade an, so richtig das zu werden, was Microsoft mal vor so 10, 15 Jahren war. Nämlich eine Sicherheitslücke nach der anderen.
Eine wird besser als die andere.
Eine besser als die andere. Und kein richtig geschicktes Händchen dabei, wie sie diese Probleme handhaben. Oder wie sie generell mit Sicherheitslücken umgehen.
Jetzt sagt noch schnell, die Sicherheitslücke, die Sendung ist gleich vorbei.
Ohne Passwort als Superadministrator anmelden.
Das ist so großartig. Probiert das mal. Wenn ihr den aktuellen Mac habt, wo das neueste Betriebssystem drauf ist, heißt das Mac OS. Probiert mal, in die Systemeinstellung zu gehen und dort auf eine Einstellung, wo ihr euch extra anmelden müsst, klickt auf das Schloss und dann steht da voreingetragen euer Username. Dann tragt ihr oben, löscht den, tragt dort root ein, R-O-O-T, drückt einfach Enter ohne ein Passwort einzugeben.
Und dann noch mal Enter.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert, noch ein paar Mal. Dann seid ihr irgendwann eingeloggt und dieses root, das ist Gott. Also Film Computer ist root Gott.
Und das ist alles.
Das ist unfassbar.
Ein imaginäres Wesen.
Es war ein schönes 2017. Ich danke euch, dass ihr hier wart.
Gerne.
Ich muss mein Apple Computer noch updaten.
Oder zumindest ein Passwort setzen.
Oder ein Passwort setzen. Wir hören uns dann im nächsten Jahr wieder, vermutlich. Hoffen wir. Wenn wir nicht expositiv bis dahin.
Und dann wieder hier.
Und dann wieder hier. Die Sendung gibt es auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Und ihr findet dann auch alle Links zu den Dingen, die ihr erwähnt habt, dort in den Show Notes. Ihr könnt die Sendung auch nochmal hören oder nochmal angucken. Und mir bleibt dieses Jahr an dieser Stelle in dieser Sendung noch einzusagen. Mein Name ist Markus Richter. Und ich möchte, dass ihr euch nicht überwachen lasst. Und immer schön eure Backups verschüsselt. Tschüss.
Tschüss.
And how many 40s they smoke.